liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen entgegen
der ursprünglichen Planung findet in
dieser Sitzungswoche keine
haushaltswoche
statt ich habe daher mit der von den
Fraktion im Ältestenrat vereinbarten
Tagesordnung
eingeladen bevor ich in die Tagesordnung
einsteige möchte ich heute eine Ausnahme
von unserer geburtstagsregel machen und
gratuliere im Namen des ganzen Hauses
meiner Vizepräsidentin Ivon mawas zu
ihrem heutigen
[Applaus]
Geburtstag nun rufe ich auf den
Tagesordnungspunkt 1 Abgabe einer
Regierungserklärung durch den
Bundeskanzler zur
Haushaltslage hierzu liegen ein
Entschließungsantrag der Fraktion der
AFD sowie ein entschließungs Antrag der
Fraktion Die Linke vor für die
Aussprache im Anschluss an die
Regierungserklärung wurde eine Dauer von
120 Minuten
vereinbart das Wort zur Abgabe der einer
Regierungserklärung hat nun der
Bundeskanzler Herr Olaf
Scholz frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und
Kollegen bevor ich auf das Thema uns
heutigen Debatte eingehe möchte ich aus
aktuellem Anlass eine Sache
voranstellen in den zurückliegenden
Tagen haben die Terroristen der her Mass
endlich Geiseln freigelassen die Geiseln
ihre Freunde und Angehörigen haben in
den vergangenen Wochen unvorstellbares
durchgemacht umso glücklicher und auch
erleichterter bin ich dass sie nun in
Freiheit und in Sicherheit
sind
das unter den freigelassenen auch
mehrere deutsche sind ist ein weiterer
Grund zur Freude allen die sich in den
zurückliegenden Tagen und Wochen für ihr
Schicksal eingesetzt haben in
unzähligigen vertraulichen Gesprächen
durch unermütliche Diplomatie sage ich
für diesen Einsatz von ganzem Herzen
Danke
natürlich ist diese Freilassung nur ein
erster Schritt noch immer hält die Hamas
mehr als 100 Frauen Männer und Kinder in
ihrer Gewalt auch sie müssen nun
unverzüglich freigelassen werden die
Bundesregierung wird dazu weiter mit
ganzer Kraft
beitragen meine Damen und Herren ich
möchte hier im Deutschen Bundestag heute
erklären wie die Regierung mit den
Folgen des jüngsten ils des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts
umgeht das Gericht hat sich am 15
November erstmals sehr detailliert und
sehr weitreichend dazu geäußert wie die
sogenannte Schuldenbremse im Grundgesetz
genau anzuwenden ist bereits zuvor gab
es in derselben Sache einen
Eilantrag schon in diesem Beschluss
hielt das Gericht mit Blick auf die
Regelung zur Schuldenbremse fest und ich
zitiere dass die
Tatbestandsvoraussetzung der
maßgeblichen Verfassungsnorm in der
Rechtsprechung des Senats bislang noch
keine Konturierung erfahren haben noch
keine Konturierung das heißt vieles im
Umgang mit der Schuldenbremse war
bislang rechtlich eher nicht eindeutig
geklärt in dieser Lage haben wir vor
zwei Jahren haushaltspolitische
Einschätzung vorgenommen die vom
Verfassungsgericht nun rechtlich
verworfen worden sind das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat dadurch
Klarheit geschaffen und das Gericht hat
das letzte WORT so ist es gute
demokratische
Tradition wissenschaftlich mag das
Urteil weiter diskutiert werden
politisch aber ist die Diskussion mit
dem Karlsruher Richterspruch
beendet mit dem Wissen um die aktuelle
Entscheidung hätten wir im Winter 2021
andere Wege beschritten Wege die das
Gericht in seinem Urteil ebenfalls
gewiesen hat dasurteil betrifft die
haushaltspraxis dieser Regierung aber
auch früherer und künftiger Regierung
das Urteil betrifft die bisherige Praxis
des Bundes genauso wie die der vieler
Länder und nicht nur weil auch die
Länder zum Teil in ganz ähnlicher Weise
wie der Bund Sondervermögen
nutzen wir haben in den vergangenen
Tagen intensiv über die folgenes Urteils
beraten diese Beratungen sind wie sollte
es anders sein noch nicht abgeschlossen
Sorgfalt geht dabei
vchnelligkeit klar ist dieses Urteil
schafft eine neue Realität für die
Bundesregierung und für alle
gegenwärtigen und die zukünftigen
Regierung im Bund und in den Ländern
eine Realität die es allerdings
schwieriger macht wichtige und weithin
geteilte Ziele für unser Land zu
erreichen schwierig geworden ist es auch
weil Deutschland in den vergangenen zwei
Jahren von schweren unvorher in äußeren
Krisen erschüttert worden ist und stellt
das vor Herausforderung wie unsere
Republik sie in dieser Konzentration und
Härte wohl noch nicht erlebt
hat 527 tsfälle und
69901 Neuansteckung am Tag so lauteten
die Zahlen im Corona Tagesbericht des
RKI am 8 Dezember 2 das war der Tag des
Amtsantritts dieser
Bundesregierung unser Land befand sich
seiner Zeit mitten in der deltaw Omikron
stand bevor ganze Wissens
Wirtschaftssektoren standen mit dem
Rücken zur Wand zwei Monate später griff
Russland die Ukraine an es gibt keinen
Zweifel daran dieser Eroberungskrieg auf
europäischenem Boden schafft auf Jahre
hinaus eine vollkommen veränderte
sicherheitspol
für Deutschland und für ganz
Europa unser Land war darauf
unzureichend vorbereitet wir haben darus
Konsequenzen gezogen übrigens auch
gemeinsam mit ihrer Fraktion Herr märz
und dafür bin ich
dankbar Deutschland ist heute der
zweitgrößte Unterstützer der Ukraine
nach den Vereinten Staaten von Amerika
auch bei den
Waffenlieferung wiren diesst fort
soangee wie nötig unsere zivile
unterstützung kommt noch hinzu über den
Bundeshaushalt und auch über den über
die Europäische Union Geld das wir
natürlich bei Regierungsantritt und vor
Kriegsbeginn nicht eingeplant hatten und
doch ist diese Unterstützung von
existenzieller
Bedeutung die Ukraine das ist klar aber
auch am Ende für uns in Europa denn
niemand von uns möchte sich ausmalen
welche noch viel gravierenderen
Konsequenzen es für uns hätte wenn Putin
diesen Krieg
gewönne mehr als eine Million Ukrainer
Ukrainer Frauen Männer und Kinder sind
innerhalb weniger Wochen vor Leid und
Tod in ihrer Heimat nach Deutschland
geflohen wir haben Sie bei uns hier
aufgenommen da das war
richtig das war ein Gebot der
Menschlichkeit aber natürlich bedeutet
die Aufnahme so vieler Menschen eine
enorme Anstrengung selbst für ein so
starkes Land wie
Deutschland kurz nach Kriegsbeginn hat
Putin dann die gastlieferung nach
Deutschland zunächst gedrosselt und
schließlich über Nacht komplett
eingestellt und eine der Röhren von
nstream 2 wurden gesprengt die Pipelines
also die uns in den kommenden Jahren mit
günstigen Gas versorgen sollten Gas das
meine Amtsvorgängerin immer wieder und
zurecht als die notwendige
brückenenergie für die Energiewende
bezeichnet hat mit dem Wegfall von
Lieferung aus Russland fehlten auf dem
Weltmarkt praktisch auf von einem Tag
auf den anderen 120 Milliarden
Kubikmeter Gas wohlgemerkt bei gleichib
Nachfrage sie alle kennen die Folgen die
Marktpreise gingen durch die Decke
zwischenzeitlich hatten sie sich mehr
als
verzehnfacht und noch immer ist Gas
unsere rückenenergie mehr als doppelt so
teuer wie zu Beginn der
Energiekrise das geht nicht spurlos
vorbei an einem Industrieland wie
Deutschland wir haben nicht nur schnell
reagiert und in Rekordzeit
flüssiggasterminals an den norddeutschen
Küsten gebaut
im vergangenen Winter
2022 haben wir bis zu 200 Milliarden
Euro bereitgestellt um den Bürgerinnen
und Bürgern und unseren Unternehmen in
dieser dramatischen Notlage die
Sicherheit zu geben die sie damit sie
zurecht
kommen und es war richtig zu helfen denn
so haben Bürger und Bürgern Bürgerinnen
und Bürgern und vielen Betrieben durch
diese enorm schwierige Zeit geholfen
dabei war von Beginn an klar es reicht
nicht aus nur auf den Winter 2022 23 zu
schauen es ging immer auch um den Winter
2023 24 von dem uns nahezu alle
expertinen und Experten einhellig gesagt
haben er können noch kritischer werden
als der
vorherige wenn wir die Mittel
die 2023 für diese Hilfen nötig gewesen
sind nun noch einmal im Haushalt
verankern dann bestätigen wir lediglich
was wir schon Ende 22 beschlossen hatten
was damals nötig und richtig war und
heute noch genauso nötig und richtig
ist die coronapandemie habe ich gerade
schon erwähnt auch hier war es nötig
richtig dass wir noch in der
Vorgängerregierung umfangreiche
coronahilfen beschlossen haben über
mehrere Jahre hinweg auch hier ging es
um Sicherheit und um eine Perspektive
für die Bürgerin und Bürger so und nur
so ist Deutschland besser durch diese
jahrhundertpandemie gekommen als viele
andere
Länder und richtig liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen dass wir unmittelbar nach dem
Beginn des russischen angisskriegs gegen
die Ukraine ein Sondervermögen
beschlossen haben um unsere Bundeswehr
über die kommenden Jahre hinweg zu
stärken und besser
aufzustellen und es war nötig und
richtig meine Damen und Herren dass wir
den Bürgern und Bürgern in rheinlandpalz
und neutrin-westfalen den Bürgern und
Bürgern im Atal geholfen haben als ihr
Hab und Gut 2021 von den Wassermassen
zerstört
wde
natürlich ist der Wiederaufbau nach
solch einer Katastrophe nicht in fün
Monaten beendet so ein Wiederaufbau
oftmals von Null dauert
Jahre wir schulden es den Opfern und den
Betroffenen vor Ort dass wir ihn dabei
solidarisch zur Seite stehen so wie wir
es gemeinsam beschlossen und versprochen
haben
wir wollen die Hilfen für das atteil und
die energiepreishilfen daher noch einmal
im Haushalt für dieses Jahr verankern
und von der Ausnahmeregel in Artikel 115
des Grundgesetzes Gebrauch machen so
schlagen wir es ihnen im Zusammenhang
mit dem nachtagshaushalt 2023 vor das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat diesen Weg
in seinem Urteil ausdrücklich gewiesen
mehr noch es hat bestätigt dass dem
Gesetzgeber in außergewöhnlichen
Notsituationen wie Artikel 115 absatz 2
Satz 6 sie vorsieht ein einschätzungs
und Beurteilungsspielraum
zukommt eine neue Realität schafft das
Urteil allerdings insofern als Hilfen in
solchen Notsituationen nun jedes Jahr
vom Bundestag neu beschlossen werden
müssen aber auch neu beschlossen werden
können damit trägt das Gericht dem
Umstand Rechnung dass die üblichen
Spielräume eines regulären Haushalts in
solchen Notsituationen eben nicht
ausreichen wie also gehen wir mit dieser
Realität nun konkret
um erstens noch am Tag des Urteils hat
der Bundesfinanzminister Ausgaben aus
dem Wirtschaftsplan des Klima und
transformationsfonds gesperrt von der
Sperre ausgenommen sind Verpflichtung
die der Bund schon vertraglich ein
gegangen ist ausgenommen sind außerdem
Maßnahmen die die Energieeffizienz und
den Einsatz erneuerbare Energien den
Gebäudebereich fördern das Gebieten die
Rechtssicherheit und die Verlässlichkeit
gegenüber den bürgerinen und
Bürgern mit einem nachtagshaushalt für
2023 werden wir zudem die Rücklage des
Klima und transformationsfonds um 60
Milliarden Euro verring
zweitens wir haben Vorsorge getroffen
damit nicht automatisch neue finanzielle
Verpflichtung für die kommenden Jahre
eingegangen werden und zwar solangee bis
wir alle Fragen präzise beantwortet
haben die sich nach dem Urteil
Stellen wichtig ist laufende Ausgaben
sind davon nicht betroffen der Staat
wird sein Aufgaben auch weiterhin
gerecht ich sage das auch an die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger gerichtet die auf
aufgrund mancher wilder Vorschläge und
manch gezielter Falschmeldung in den
sozialen Medien verunsichert sind in
ihrem Alltag hier und heute ändert das
Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts
nichts völlig unabhängig davon ob sie
Kindergeld oder barfk bekommen eine
Rente oder
Wohngeld
drittens wir stellen sicher
dass der laufende Haushalt 223 allen
Vorgaben des Bundesverfassungsgerichts
entspricht das Kabinett hat gestern dem
Entwurf eines Nachtragshaushaltes für
223 zugestimmt dieser wurde dem
Bundestag als Haushaltsgesetzgeber
zugeleitet zudem werden wir dem
Bundestag wie schon gesagt vorschlagen
ein Beschluss gemäß Artikel 115 Absatz 2
des Grundgesetzes zu fassen ich habe es
gerade
erwähnt damit sichern wir nachträglich
die Energiepreis Bremsen für 2023 ab die
im Zuge des russischen angriffskriegs
gegen die Ukraine erforderlich geworden
sind das ist wichtig für die Bürgerin
und Bürger für unsere krankenhiseer und
für die Unternehmen und damit sichern
wir auch die Unterstützung für die vom
Hochwasser betroffenen Familien in
rheinlandfalz und
nordrheinwestfalentig die bereits vom
Bundestag bewilligtmittel zur
krisenbewältung auf eine andere
Rechtsgrundlage so tragen wir den
Vorgaben des
verfassungsgerichtsrechnung aber eben
auch der Tatsache dass die
energiepreiskrise jetzt wohl definitiv
noch nicht ganz beendet ist und die
Zerstörung nach einer Jahrhundertflut
noch nicht beseitigt
sind dass wir die energiepreisbremsen
gleich wohl zu Beginn des kommenden
Jahres beenden können hat einen
einfachen Grund inzwischen sind überall
in Deutschland wieder Strom und
Gastarife verfügbar die zwar deutlich
höher liegen als vor der Krise aber
meist unterhalb der Obergrenzen die wir
für die preisbremsen gezogen haben und
ebenfalls spürbar unterhalb der Preise
im vergangenen Herbst und Winter unsere
gastspeicher haben wir zudem so gut
gefüllt dass wir nicht mit plötzlichen
Preissprüngen rechnen klar ist aber auch
sollten die Preise für Energie dennoch
erneut dramatisch steigen sind wir jeder
Zeit in der Lage kurzfristig zu
handeln viertens die Regierungsfraktion
haben vergangene Woche beschlossen über
die Auswirkung des Urteils auf den
Haushaltsentwurf für 2024 ausführlich zu
beraten dafür haben sie den Abschluss
der Haushaltsberatung
verschoben das gibt uns Zeit vorhandene
Spiel Räume im Haushalt auszuloten
Schwerpunkte zu setzen und natürlich
auch Ausgaben zu
beschränken zusammen mit dem Bundestag
arbeiten wir nun intensiv daran alle
Beschlüsse die für den Haushalt 2024
nötig sind so schnell wie möglich zu
treffen denn die Bürgerin und Bürger und
unsere Unternehmen brauchen in unruhigen
Zeiten
Klarheit
und ganz klar
ist die Bürgerin und Bürger können
darauf vertrauen dass der Staat seine
Zusagen ihnen gegenüber
einhält wir lassen niemanden allein mit
den Herausforderungen mit denen wir es
aktuell so gebalt zu tun
haben you never walk alone das habe ich
im vergangenen Jahr versprochen und
dabei bleibt
es
weiß jetzt nicht wie ich ihren Spaß da
interpretieren soll aber vielleicht ja
so you walk without Christian Democratic
Union also das ist vielleicht kein so
guter
Einfall am Ende geht es dabei auch um
etwas
Grundsätzliches nämlich um den
Zusammenhalt in unserem Land um den
Sozialstaat es geht um die Frage
steh jeder für sich allein wenn es
schwierig wird oder haken wir uns unter
ich bin zuefst überzeugt wir alle kommen
besser zurecht wenn wir niemanden
zurücklassen wir alle kommen besser
zurecht wenn wir uns den Herausforderung
Seite an Seite
stellen klar ist auch in unserer
Unterstützung der Ukraine und bei der
Bewältigung der Energiekrise dürfen wir
auf keinen Fall nachlassen das wäre
nicht verantwortlich das würde unsere
Zukunft
gefährden und zugleich wäre es ein
schwerer ein unverzeilicher Fehler über
die Bewältigung all dieser akuten
Herausforderung die Modernisierung
unseres Landes zu
vernachlässigen
und richtig sie schafft die
Voraussetzung für gute Arbeitsplätze und
eine starke Wirtschaft damit das
Fundament unseres künftigen Wohlstands
gesichert bleibt natürlich haben auch
die regierungschefinen und
Regierungschefs der Länder das
allergrößte Interesse daran dass
Zukunftsinvestitionen bei Ihnen vor Ort
auch zustande kommen Investition etwa in
schiffindustrie KL oder
B Zeug nur wenn sich Deutschland
modernisiert werden wir in der Lage sein
auch künftig auf unvorhergesehene Krisen
kraftvoll zu
reagieren meine Damen und Herren wir
haben zu Beginn unserer Regierung
entschieden nicht länger zuzusehen wie
Deutschlands
Infrastruktur
verfät und zwar klar wir müssen jetzt
kraftvoll in die Modernisierung
Deutschlands investieren wir müssen
jetzt dafür sorgen dass wir in
Deutschland die Transformation unserer
Wirtschaft hinbekommen und als starkes
Industrieland wettbewerbsfähig
bleiben und wir müssen jetzt alles daran
setzen die Energiewende in Deutschland
und Europa endlich voranzubringen die
von vielen Vorgängerregierung
versprochen wurde aber nials wirklich
umgesetzt
wir müssen jetzt den Reformstau auflösen
wir müssen jetzt Tempo machen nach
Jahren des
Stillstands zu all diesen Zielen stehe
ich an all diesen Zielen arbeitet die
von mir geführte Bundesregierung von Tag
1 an die großen Modernisierungsvorhaben
für unser Land sind nicht hinfällig
geworden im Gegenteil
egal wo man hinschaut ob in die USA oder
nach Frankreich nach China oder Japan
überall sind Regionen dabei massiv in
die Zukunft zu investieren weltweit
investieren Länder in moderne und
digitale Infrastruktur in saubere
Energieversorgung und in
klimafreundliche
Technologien wir sind mitten im Aufbruch
in eine neue era vergleichbar in seiner
Dimension nur mit dem Aufbruch in das
Industriezeitalter jetzt schon in den
allernächsten Jahren entscheidet sich wo
künftig Wertschöpfung stattfindet wo
Innovation und Wohlstand zu Hause sind
in einer klimaneutralen
Welt ich will dass Deutschland ganz
vorne dabei ist denn es geht für uns
alle um viel es geht um sichere
Arbeitsplätze es geht um eine
wettbewerbsfähige Wirtschaft
es geht um ein gutes Leben für kommende
Generation und es geht um unsere
Fähigkeit auch künftige Krisen sicher zu
bewältigen mit diesen klaren Prämissen
beraten wir jetzt über den Haushalt für
das kommende Jahr mit der nötigen Ruhe
und in Verantwortung für unser Land
darauf können die Bürger und Bürger sich
verlassen dafür stehe als Bundeskanzler
ich danke
ih Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz hier mit
der Regierungserklärung in der quasi für
jeden etwas drin war er hat sich hier
als souveräner Staatsmann gezeigt der
den Bürgern verspricht dass alles gut
wird er hat noch mal erklärt wie es dazu
kommen konnte dass man jetzt ein
agshaushalt für das Jahr
2023 einbringen muss er hat an einer
Stelle gesagt dass wir
energiebeisbremsen zu Beginn des
kommenden Jahres beenden können da hat
die Sozialdemokratie nicht mitgeklatscht
an der Stelle und er hat an anderer
Stelle gesagt dass man aber doch als
moderne Industrienation jetzt nicht
stehen bleiben kann sondern dass jetzt
modernisiert werden muss daraus kann man
interpretieren dass er gewillt wäre auch
weitere Schritte fiskalisch zu gehen
aber zu fiskalischen Schritten hat er
leider gar nichts gesagt und das mag den
ein oder anderen ein wenig enttäuschen
ein typischer Olaf Scholz will ich mal
sagen der hier etwas tronend über allem
das kennen wir auch von Angela Merkel
natürlich versucht hat die Bürger zu
beruhigen er habe alles im Griff ich
denke dass der Oppositionsführer
Friedrich März dazu seine eigenen
Anmerkung machen wird meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren lassen Sie
mich zunächst zu beginnen sagen
dass wir den
Dank und die Erleichterung Teilen die
Sie Herr Bundeskanzler zu Beginn ihrer
Regierungserklärung zum Ausdruck
gebracht haben im Hinblick auf die
Freilassung wenigstens einer einiger der
Geiseln die sich in den letzten Wochen
in der Hand der
hamasterroristen in Israel befunden
haben und ich will ausdrücklich im Namen
unserer Fraktion sag s wir danken
denjenigen die aus ihrer Regierung daran
beteiligt waren dies zu erreichen
ausdrücklich herzlichen Dank an
Sie meine Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir sprechen
heute so war es
jedenfalls bis zum Beginn der Rede Herr
Bundeskanzler mein Eindruck über die
folg
der Entscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes vom
15 November das Bundesverfassungsgericht
hat eine Entscheidung getroffen die den
Haushaltsgesetzgeber im Bund und in den
Ländern in Zukunft zu einer strikten
Ausgabendisziplin
verpflichtet diese Entscheidung ist in
der Sache richtig sie kommt zum
richtigen Zeitpunkt und sie war vor
allem notwendig lassen Sie mich das
einmal deutlich sagen
weil darüber ein falscher Eindruck auch
in Teilen der veröffentlichten Meinung
entstanden ist wir haben über dieses
Urteil nicht
triumphiert und ist unds ist die
Tragweite dieser Entscheidung des
Verfassungsgerichtes sehr wohl
bewusst aber Herr Bundeskanzler diese
Entscheidung ist notwendig
geworden weil ihre Regierung den Versuch
unternommen hat die Verschuldung gr
Enzen des Grundgesetzes in einer in
bisher in Deutschland nicht gekannten
gerade zu dreisten Art und Weise zu
umgehen und um hier so gleich den
Behauptungen zu widersprechen die ganz
sicher von den Rednern der Koalition
hier gleich vorgetragen werden das war
weder eine Klage von uns gegen den
Klimaschutz noch gegen die notwendigen
Hilfen für die privaten Haushalte und
die Unternehmen in Deutschland noch war
sie dagegen gerichtet was auch frühere
Regierungen schon einmal versucht haben
das war eine Klage die gegen die bereits
in ihrem Koalitionsvertrag
aufgeschriebene von jeder bisherigen
Staatspraxis abweichenden Manipulation
unserer
Verfassung en
war eine Vereinbarung in ihrem
Koalitionsvertrag die dem Ziel
diente zum einen dem Wunsch der FDP zu
entsprechen auf Steuererhöhungen und auf
die Aussetzung der Schuldenbremse zu
verzichten und zum anderen die
ungehemmte Subvention aller
Klimaprojekte der Bundesregierung weiter
zu ermöglichen und zum dritten die
Aufblähung des Sozialstaates für die
Sozialdemokraten zu zu ermöglichen diese
Quadratur des Kreises haben sie versucht
und dieses Kartenhaus ist am 15 November
2023 zusammengebrochen das war das
Ergebnis der Entscheidung von
Karlsruhe und meine Damen und Herren der
Urheber der Urheber dieser
verfassungswidrigen Konstruktion war
kein geringerer als sie Herr
Bundeskanzler sie haben nämlich in der
Übergangszeit der früheren Regierung auf
die neue Regierung noch in ihrer
Funktion als
Bundesfinanzminister genau diese wie wir
heute nun dezidiert Wissen
verfassungswiedrige Konstruktion erdacht
dazu hätte ich von ihnen
erwartet nachdem Sie nun
eine eine solche Niederlage vor dem
Verfassungsgericht haben einstecken
müssen übrigens schon die zweite in
wenigen Wochen dazu hätten wir erwartet
dass es wenigstens mal ein Wort des
Bedauerns von ihnm gegeben hätte wenn
nicht auch ein Wort der Entschuldigung
hier angebracht gewesen wäre Herr
Bundeskanzler sie wissen doch sonst
immer alles vor allem wissen Sie immer
alles besser als alle anderen sie haben
hier eben die 41 Seiten sie haben hier
eben die Vorentscheidung zitiert ist
ihnen aus dieser Vorentscheidung nicht
aufgefallen welche konkreten drei Punkte
das Bundesverfassungsgericht genannt hat
für die Hauptsache Entscheidung die dann
anschließend genauso gefolgt ist wie
eine ganze Reihe von Fachleuten der
Bundesrat ihre Mitglieder in der
Bundesregierung doch teilweise auch
ihnen vorausgesagt haben sie hätten es
wissen können was das
bundesverfassungsricht am 15 November
2023 entscheidet Absturz eines
besserwissers nennt das der Spiegel in
seiner Titelgeschichte in dieser Woche
und besser hätte es gar nicht eben
werden
können nun will ich nicht nur hier
Kritik üben heute morgen sondern ich
will mich weil es gerade von ihen so
viel Zwischenrufe gibt ich will mich bei
einem Mitglied der Bundesregierung auch
einmal ausdrücklich und sehr herzlich
bedanken das ist der Vizekanzler Herr
habck sie haben es für richtig gehalten
bei ihrem Parteitag in der letzten Woche
meine Partei die CDU als eine Partei aus
den 90er Jahren zu bezeichnen damit habe
ich gerechnet dass das bei ihnen kommt
vielen Dank ich empfinde es nämlich
wirklich als ein großes Kompliment was
sie da gesagt haben wir hatten nämlich
wir hatten in den 90er Jahren
Wirtschaftsminister auf der
Regierungsbank sitzen die wirklich etwas
von Wirtschaftspolitik verstanden
haben
wir wir
hatten wir hatten
Außenminister wir hatten Außenminister
auf der Regierungsbank sitzen die nicht
mit erhobenem Zeigefinger durch die Welt
gereist sind die überall hoch anerkannt
waren und von denen kein einziger auf
den Gedanken gekommen wäre sich bei
einer Israel Resolution bei den
Vereinten Nationen für Deutschland der
Stimme zu enthalten ja kein einziger auf
die Idee
gekommen und wir Wirten ein
Finanzminister Finanzminister Theo
Weigel der in 10 Jahren trotz größter
fiskalischer Herausforderungen
Deutschland sicher in die Währungsunion
geführt hat und Herr Bundeskanzler wir
hatten mit Helmut Kohl einen
Bundeskanzler auf der Regierungsbank
sitzen der mit der deutschen Einheit mit
dem europäischen Binnenmarkt und mit der
Währungsunion wirklich Geschichte für
Deutschland und Europa geschrieben hat
davon sind sie doch Lichtjahre entfernt
insbesondere mit der Regierungserklärung
die sie heute morgen hier abgegeben
haben nun kann man ja vom Rednerpult aus
nicht immer die Regierung jeden Tag und
jede Minute hier anschauen aber wenn sie
mal gesehen hätten wie ihre Regierung
hier welchen Gesichtsausdruck ihre
Regierung bei ihrer Regierungserklärung
hatte meine Damen und Herren das ist
jetzt heute das ist die Regierung der
viertgrößten Volkswirtschaft der Welt es
ist einfach es ist einfach nur noch
peinlich was wir von ihnen hier sehen
und
hören und Herr Bundeskanzler Herr
Bundeskanzler sie haben sie haben im
Februar des letzten Jahres von dieser
Stelle aus eine viel beachtete
Regierungserklärung abgegeben mit dem
Wort Zeitenwende dieses Wort findet in
ihrer regierungsheute Erklärung heute
keine Erwähnung mehr was sie hier
vorgetragen haben sind doch rein
technische Antworten auf eine
hochpolitische Entscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes sie sind ein
klemtner der macht ihnen fehlt jede
Vorstellung davon wie dieses Land sich
in den nächsten Jahren weiter entwickeln
soll sie haben keine Ahnung von dem was
da in den nächsten Jahren auf sie und
auf uns zukommt es tut mir herzlich leid
aber ich muss es nach dieser ich muss es
nach dieser Regierungserklärung einmal
so deutlich sagen ich will es nicht
überstrapazzieren und will ihnen nicht
zu viele Vergleiche zumuten aber
verglichen allein mit den Kanzlern die
ihre einstmals so stolze Partei die SPD
hier in Deutschland gestellt hat
verglichen mit Willi Brand verglichen
mit Helmut Schmidt sogar mit sogar mit
Gerhard Schröder muss man doch
spätestens nach dieser
Regierungserklärung von heute morgen zu
dem Schluss kommen sie können es nicht
die Schuhe Herr Bundeskanzler die Schuhe
in denen sie
stehen die Schuhe in denen sie
bueskanzler der bundesreublik Deutsch
die sind ihen mindestens zwei schnummer
zu groß anders kann man es nicht sagen
nachdem was wir heute morgen hier von
ihnen gehört
haben aber die Lage unseres Landes ist
zu ernst als dass wir daran nun Freude
haben könnten sie gefährden mit ihrer
Politik den Wohlstand und die Zukunft
unseres
landesem Zukunft unserer Kinder und
Enkelkinder wir müssen möglicherweise
damit rechnen dass sie nach den letzten
Turbulenzen in ihrer Koalition der
letzten zwei Woche jetzt noch versuchen
zwei Jahre über Wasser zu bleiben und
die Streiterein und die Konflikte in
ihrer Koalition einfach so weitergehen
und damit die nachfolgenden Redner der
Koalition hier sofort die Antwort von
mir bekommen sie werden uns wieder an
unsere staatspolitische Verantwortung
erinnern die wir in diesem Lande tragen
ja das werden sie ja tun so ich will ih
ich will ihn meine Damen und Herren ich
will ihn die Antwort geben was wir als
staatspolitische Verantwortung unserer
Fraktion empfinden die wichtigste ist
ihnen auf die Finger zu schauen und wann
immer dies notwendig ist dafür zu sorgen
dass sie jedenfalls mit den uns zur
Verfügung stehenden Mitteln dazu
gezwungen werden unsere Verfassung
einzuhalten das ist zunächst einmal das
allerwichtigste und nur damit
sie und damit sie nicht
wieder sie nicht wieder überrascht sind
was dann möglicherweise das
Bundesverfassungsgericht später
entscheidet will ich Sie daran erinnern
dass noch fünf Verfahren vor dem
Bundesverfassungsgericht gegen ihre
Regierung anhängig sind zur Wahlprüfung
hier in Berlin zum heizungsgesetzung zum
heizungsgesetz zur Verkürzung der
informations und auskunftflichten des
Parlaments zur Verweigerung eines
Untersuchungsausschusses in Sachen
scholz-wburg ein einmaliger Vorgang in
der Parlamentsgeschichte dass
Minderheitenrechte des Parlamentes so
missachtet werden wie von ihnen und
schließlich gegen die manulation des
Wahlrechts darauf können Sie sich
einstellen für die nächsten Wochen und
Monate weitere Entscheidungen des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes legen Sie
sich diese Liste ganz oben auf Ihren
Schreibtisch damit sie nicht vergessen
was das bundesverfassungsgricht noch zu
entscheiden hat in den nächsten
Wochen
unsere unsere staatspolitische
Verantwortung besteht außerdem darin
Ihnen immer dann wenn wir es in der
Sache für richtig halten zuzustimmen und
an den Gesetzen unseres Landes tiv
mitzuwirken das haben wir in den letzten
Z Jahren getan ja meine Damen und Herren
es ist ihnen möglicherweise entgangen
mich hat auch etwas überrascht aber wir
haben mehr als der Hälfte der Gesetze
ihrer Koalition im Deutschen Bundestag
zugestimmt manchem vielleicht hätten wir
gar nicht zustimmen sollen wir haben es
getan aus Überzeugung weil auch
Kompromisse notwendig sein müssen hier
im Parlament unsere staatspolitische
Verantwortung unsere staatspolitische
Verantwortung meine Damen und Herren äge
zu machen wie wir wieder auf einen Weg
zurückkehren können mit
umweltverträglichem Wachstum und hoher
Beschäftigung ohne dabei unsere
Staatshaushalte zu ruinieren und damit
Sie sich bitte keine Illusionen machen
damit Sie sich bitte keine Illusionen
machen wir werden an der Schuldenbremse
des Grundgesetzes festhalten und
versuchen Sie erst gar nicht versuchen
Sie erst gar
nicht gar nicht einen Keil in die Union
zu treiben wir versuchen Sie es erst gar
nicht versuchen Sie es nicht meine Damen
und Herren die Entscheidungen werden
hier im Deutschen Bundestag getroffen
und nicht im Rathaus von Berlin wir
entscheiden hier darüber wo wir
entscheiden hier
darüber und wir reden und meine Damen
und Herren wir reden nicht nur wir reden
nicht nur über Nachhaltigkeit in der
Umweltpolitik wir reden auch über nach
in den Staatsfinanzen und wir werden
ihnen nicht die Hand dazu reichen wieder
zurückzufallen in die alten
sozialdemokratischen Muster einer stetig
steigenden Staatsverschuldung und
übrigens an dieser Stelle her
Bundeskanzler
Bundeskanzler da stehen in den nächsten
Tagen da stehen in den da stehen in den
nächsten Tagen in Brüssel einige
Entscheidungen zur Wirtschafts und
Währungsunion und zur Fortsetzung des
Stabilitäts und wachstumspaktes an wir
müssen ihnen dabei helfen dass auch
Deutschland ein klares Signal der
stabilen Staatsfinanzen in der
Währungsunion kommt wenn in Deutschland
die Dämme brechen werden sie auch in
allen anderen Ländern der Währungsunion
nicht halten da hat Deutschland eine
Vorbildfunktion und die müssen sie ob
sie wollen oder nicht auch
wahrnehmen und dann sage ich ihn sehr
konkret dann sage ich ihn sehr konkret
zu den Themen wo wir Ihnen anbieten
etwas besser zu machen wenn Sie Ihre
wirtschaftsenergie und Umweltpolitik neu
ausrichten wollen mit wirklicher
Technologie Offenheit und mit
marktwirtschaftlichen Instrumenten wie
ja ich weiß bei diesem Wort reagieren
sie sofort allergisch Marktwirtschaft
verstehen sie überhaupten können sie
nicht mehr schreiben geschweige denn
auch wirklich Politik machen damit meine
Damen und Herren wenn sie das wollen
statt der staatlichen Steuerung und
Subvention aller Transformationsprozesse
dann haben Sie uns an Ihrer Seite wenn
Sie Arbeitsmarktpolitik ändern wollen
mit dem Ziel einer mit dem Ziel einer
vernünftigen Balance zwischen fördern
und fordern wenn Sie wollen dass sich
Beschäftigung im Arbeitsmarkt immer und
grundsätzlich mehr lohnt als der Bezug
von Transferleistungen dann haben sie
uns an ihrer
Seite und wenn Sie darauf verzichten
wollen unter der Überschrift der
kindergrundsicherungst einm 5000 neue
Stellen im öffentlichen Dienst zu
schaffen wenn Sie darauf verzichten
wollen Herr Bundeskanzler dann haben sie
uns an ihrer Seite und wenn sie
überhaupt einmal aufhören dieses Land
bis mit einer bisher nie gekannten
Bürokratie zu überziehen dann haben sie
uns an ihrer Seite und Herr
Bundeskanzler wenn Sie mit uns reden
wollen wie wir das gegebenenfalls
gemeinsam auf den Weg bringen dann
kommen Sie gern zu mir und dann können
wir über fast alles miteinander reden
aber wenn sie aber wenn sie mit ihrer
Regierung so weitermachen wie bisher und
ihre Regierungserklärung von heute
Morgen gibt einen das sichere Gefühl
dass sie keinerlei Veränderungen an dem
vornehmen wollen was sie in ihrer
Rechthaberei in den letzten Wochen und
Monaten hier gesagt und getan haben wenn
sie weiter uneinsichtig sind wenn sie
weiter streiten wenn sie weiter unsere
Staatsfinanzen gefährden und unsere
Volks Wirtschaft vor die Wand fahren
dann werden wir alles dafür tun dass der
Spuk mit ihrer Bundesregierung so
schnell wie möglich beendet wird meine
Damen und Herren das ist die
staatspolitische Verantwortung der
Opposition in diesem Deutschen Bundestag
mit ihrer Bundesregierung Herr
Bundeskanzler der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland ein sehr kämpferischer
oppositionsschiff der hier quasi den
Bundeskanzler persönlich Angriff und wie
schrieb eben ein Kollege in einer
Agentur zerlegt hat sie sind ein
klemtner der macht ihnen fehlt jegliche
Vorstellung wie sie sich das Land
fortentwickeln soll verglichen mit Brand
Schmidt Schröder muss man spätestens
nach der Regierungserklärung heute
morgen sagen und feststellen sie können
es nicht Herr Bundeskanzler sie
gefährden mit ihrer Politik den
Wohlstand und die Zukunft unserer Kinder
das war eine Rede die alles andere als
hoffnungsfroh für die in die Zukunft
blicken lässt dass es vielleicht doch
noch so etwas wie eine gemeinsame große
Anstrengung in diesem Land geben könnte
zusammen mit der CDU CSU um die Probleme
der Zukunft gemeinsam zu lösen ich
glaube jedem in der Ampel ist nach dem
heutigen Tag zumindest klar das muss die
Ampel Miteinander regeln vor allen
Dingen auch die Frage wie nun der
Haushalt 2024 aussehen soll was wo
gestrichen wird und wo weiter investiert
werden kann diese Frage müssen die
Koalition Koalitionäre untereinander und
dazu hat der Bundeskanzler relativ wenig
gesagt aber er hat gesagt
Gründlichkeit geht vor Schnelligkeit was
darauf schließen lässt dass er eher zu
denen gehört der sagt es kommt nicht
unbedingt darauf an vor Weihnachten
diesen Haushalt hier noch abzuschließen
oder in diesem Jahr gar da gab es schon
die Überlegung zwischen den Jahren
eventuell V all aus der Sozialdemokratie
das hörte sich beim Bundeskanzler ganz
anders
an Applaus ist immer gut für alle und äh
jetzt jetzt fahren wir weiter in der
Debatte
und als nächst hat das Wort für die
Fraktion Bündnis 90 Katharina
dröge ja selten hat die Union meine Rede
so begeistert
angekündigt aber im Ernst sehr geehrte
Frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen sehr geehrter Herr März sie
hätten heute eine Chance gehabt sie
hätten eine Chance
gehabt sich hier als Mann darzustellen
der vielleicht auch irgendwann einmal
wieder Verantwortung in diesem Land
tragen möchte sie hätten eine Chance
gehabt eine Rede zu halten die der Lage
angemessen gewesen wäre und ich frage
mich warum gelingt ihnen das eigentlich
nie warum schaffen sie es
nicht selbst in einer Situation wie
dieser nicht einmal den Eindruck zu
erwecken dass die Menschen in diesem
Land und dass die Unternehmen die sich
gerade um ihre Zukunft sorgen dass die
ihnen wichtiger sind dass sie sich mit
mit den ernsthafter beschäftigen als mit
parteitaktischen hin und her und
billigen Punkten für die Union warum
schaffen sie das
nicht die Realität die sieht nämlich
folgendermaßen aus
738 Milliarden Dollar 738 Milliarden
Dollar das ist das was die USA
investieren um die amerikanische
Wirtschaft nach vorne zu bringen um mit
Klima
neue Jobs zu schaffen 738 Milliarden
Dollar das ist eine Zahl die aus meiner
Sicht eins deutlich macht wer hier nicht
mitspielt verliert wer nicht bereit ist
in relevanter Größenordnung einzusteigen
bei Investitionen in grüne Technologien
bei Investitionen in Infrastruktur die
die Zukunft bringen der wird im
Wettbewerb zwischen den größten
Wirtschaftsräumen der Welt gnadenlos
verlieren und ehrlich gesagt das sollte
niemen kan zumindest für diese Koalition
sagen wir wollen das explizit nicht wir
wollen das Unternehmen Jobs in
Deutschland schaffen wenn sie
batteriefabriken investieren oder in die
Chipproduktion wir wollen das
Unternehmen Energieeffizienz investieren
weil sie was fürs Klima bringen aber
weil sie den Unternehmen eben auch
Kosten sparen wir wollen das Unternehmen
den Sprung wagen in neue Technologien
Stahl erzeugt mit grünem Wasserstoff
Zement produziert mit deutlich weniger
CO2 wir wollen das solarm Module wieder
in Sachsen hergestellt werden und
deswegen ist es notwendig dass wir hier
weiter investieren und dass wir die
Wirtschaft an dieser Stelle
unterstützen und ich bin wirklich froh
dass es dafür mittlerweile auch breite
Unterstützung gibt alle
Wirtschaftsminister vom Bund und in
allen Bundesländern gemeinsam jeder
politischen Farbe haben sich gestern
gemeinsam dafür ausgesprochen dass die
Investition im Klima und Transformation
fortgesetzt werden können so sieht das
nämlich aus wenn die CDU irgendwo
Verantwortung trägt dann erkennt sie
auch die Realität uns geht es um die
Zukunft des Wirtschaftsstandortes
Deutschland uns geht es darum dass
unsere Unternehmen international
wettbewerbsfähig sind uns geht es darum
100tausende Arbeitsplätze in diesem Land
zukunftsfähig zu erhalten und deshalb
ist es keine gute Nachricht und es kann
auch keine gute Nachricht aus Sicht
einer Oppositionsfraktion sein auch
nicht aus s der CDU wenn nach dem Urteil
des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes 60 Milliarden
Euro im Klima und transformationsfond
nicht mehr genutzt werden können und
dann kann man sich hier nicht so
schulterzuckend hinstellen und sagen ist
mir doch egal wenn diese Investition
nicht mehr möglich sind ist mir doch
egal wenn die Wirtschaft dann in eine
Wirtschaftskrise rutscht das Geld ist
eben weg sie haben hier mit ihrem
Gelächter ziemlich deutlich gemacht dass
ihnen das Schicksal von Unternehmen die
gerade Sorgen um diese Zukunft machen
dass i das Schicksal von Beschäftigten
in diesem Land die Antworten brauchen
ehrlich gesagt ziemlich egal sind sie
finden das ja sogar
lustig und ich muss Ihnen
sagen ich werfe ihnen nicht vor dass sie
geklagt haben ich werfe ihnen nicht vor
dass sie geklabt haben es ist das gute
Recht einer Opposition Gesetze auch
welche die sie selbst in ähnliche Art
und Weise gemacht haben das ist hier
egal Gesetze in K überprüfen zu lassen
das W ihn nicht vor und ich sage auch
ganz deutlich das Urteil aus karlsr das
ist sonnenklar das ist hart das ist klar
das ist eindeutig so wie wir den
Nachtragshaushalt 2021 gebucht haben so
ging es offensichtlich nicht das haben
wir als Regierung gemeinsam falsch
eingeschätzt und das bedauern wir das
kann ich ganz klar sagen das war für
niemanden gut dass wir das falsch
eingeschätzt haben und das räumen wir
jetzt auf das ist die Verantwortung der
wir uns stellen Schritt für
Schritt
das erste was wir machen ist der
Nachtragshaushalt
2023 wir schaffen Sicherheit Sicherheit
für die Menschen die angewiesen waren in
einer Energiekrise auf Gas und
strompreisbremsen mit denen wir in einem
schwierigen Winter im letzten und in
diesem bezahlbare Energiepreise
garantiert haben und das ist wichtig wir
schaffen auch jetzt den Prozess für den
Haushalt 2024 und ja das gebe ich auch
ganz un im Wunden zu da liegt in dieser
Koalition noch ein Stück Arbeit vor uns
da müssen wir uns noch darauf
verständigen weil das Urteil von
karlsruh nicht einfach war weil der
Wirich auch nicht leicht ist das jetzt
zu realisieren aber wir haben ganz klar
miteinander gesagt wir als
koalitionsfraktion wir verhandeln das
Miteinander wir werden Lösung finden wir
werden das zügig umsetzen und mit der
notwendigen Sorgfalt darauf können sich
die Menschen in diesem Land
verlassen und sie ja März sie haben ja
jetzt in ihrer Rede vor allen Dingen
gesagt was mit ihnen alles nicht geht
und das finde ich sehr bedauerlich und
deswegen muss ich noch mal positiv
anerkennen es gibt zum Glück nicht nur
eine Union es gibt zum Glücklich auch
noch eine Union die in Bundesländern
Verantwortung trägt die weiß wie es sich
anfühlt wenn man ein Land regiert die
weiß wie es sich anfühlt wenn man vor
den Unternehmen steht und Ihnen sagt wie
geht es weiter und diese Union die hat
zum Glück auch konstruktive Vorschläge
gemacht Herr Wegner Herr kretschm Herr
Haselhoff Herr wüst die alle haben
Vorschläge gemacht die wir sehr
ernsthaft miteinander diskutieren können
das begrüße ich aus
drücklich wenn die Ministerpräsidenten
der Union sagen sie halten eine
Modernisierung der Schuldenbremse für
notwendig dann kann ich für mich sagen
ich finde das nachvollziehbar denn die
Schuldenbremse so wie sie handwerklich
damals auch von ihnen ausgestaltet wurde
die führt nicht dazu dass wir weniger
Schulden machen die führt im Endeffekt
nur dazu dass wir schulden in der
sinnlosesten aller möglichen Formen
machen wenn
wir wenn wir künftigen Generationen
kaputte Autobahnbrücken hinterlassen
dann hinterlassen wir Ihnen auch
Schulden denn künftige Generationen
können diese Brücken in Zukunft ja nicht
alle zusammenbrechen lassen das würde in
Deutschland einen Verkehrskollaps herauf
beseschwören den niemand wollen kann
deswegen zuk
en m nur dann wirben teurer weil wir zu
SP gehandelt haben dann wird komter dann
gibt es mehr Ärger und deswegen ist das
die sinnloseste Form von Verschuldung
die man sich ausdenken kann und
generationengerecht ist daran gar nichts
man kann auch andere Vorschläge
diskutieren Daniel Günther in
Schleswigholstein ist mit seiner
Regierung einen Weg gegangen er hat
jetzt gesagt krisenbedingt erklären wir
die Notlage auch noch mal für den
Haushalt 204 20 und ja der Krieg in der
Ukraine der Krieg von Russland dauert an
und er wird sogar schlimmer und deswegen
ist es wichtig dass wir all unsere
Anstrengung weiterhin darauf
konzentrieren die Ukraine zu
unterstützen mit Waffen mit humanitärer
Hilfe und dass wir hier unsere
Anstrengung eher noch verstärken als
dass wir darin nachlassen und deswegen
finde ich es sinnvoll dass Daniel
Günther gesagt hat lasst uns alles offen
prüfen auch diesen Weg und jetzt komme
ich zu dem was sie vorgeschlagen Herr
märz und da fehlt es mir wirklich an
Ernsthaftigkeit und ein Stück weit auch
an Anstand das ausgerechnet von ihnen
als allererster Vorschlag kam bei der
Bekämpfung von Kinderarmut kürzen zu
wollen das finde ich wirklich schäig
ausgerechnet bei der Bekämpfung von
Kinderarmut ich hätte gedacht es wäre
Konsens unter demokratischen Parteien
dass wir alle dafür verpflichtet sind
das bestmöglich Aufwachsen von Kindern
in diesem Land zu garantieren
ausgerechnet bei den Schwächsten in
dieser Gesellschaft als erstes zu kürzen
ausgerechnet bei denjenigen die wir am
meisten schützen müssen und die wir am
meisten unterstützen zu müssen dass das
der allererste Vorschlag ist der ihnen
eingefallen ist hier zu kürzen da haben
sie komplett den Kompass
verloren und eine zweite bitte hören Sie
auf mit dem Bürgergeld zündeln sie
wissen selber dass ist ein Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes gibt das uns
aufgetragen hat dass wir Menschen im
Bürgergeld ein menschenwürdiges
Existenzminimum garantieren müssen ich
persönlich finde das in der Sache auch
absolut richtig politisch und moralisch
aber selbst wenn sie das nicht teilen
selbst wenn sie das aus irgendwelchen
Gründen nicht richtig finden Menschen
ein menschenwürdiges Existenzminimum zu
garantieren dann müssen sie anerkennen
dass das nicht gilt dann müssen sie
erkennen dass das auch ein Grund war
warum wir das Bürgergeld im letzten Jahr
gemeinsam reformiert haben und sie im
übrigen zugestimmt haben weil uns das
Bundesverfassungsgericht das aufgetragen
hat und Redlichkeit in der Politik
bedeutet dass man sich nicht nur ein
Urteil aussucht das einem gefällt weil
man damit gerade der Bundesregierung
Probleme machen kann Redlichkeit in der
Politik bedeutet dann dass man jedes
Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts
ernst nimmt das zum Bürgergeld das zum
Klimaschutz und das zum Haushalt dann
ist man eine ernsthafte Rechtsstaats
Teil wir haben diesen Anspruch wir
machen ernsthafte Politik für dieses
Land und ich kann sie wirklich nur
einladen nehmen Sie alle Urteile Ernst
danke Katharina dröge eine der beiden
Fraktionsvorsitzenden der
Bündnisgrünen hat sich hier vor allen
Dingen auch mit herrm März beschäftigt
und ihm noch mal Schäbigkeit vorgeworfen
dass ihm ausgerechnet als erstes
einfällt bei den Kindern zu sparen sie
hat aufgefordert eine konstruktive
Mitarbeit und ihre Hoffnung Ausdruck
gegeben dass die in der CDU zu finden
sei denn viele Ministerpräsidenten seien
ja durchaus offen für die Modernisierung
der Schuldenbremse Alis Weidel
jetzt die Fraktionschefin der
[Applaus]
AFD sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Bundeskanzler sehr Gerte Damen
her keine zwei Jahre Ampel und
Deutschland steckt in der Dauerkrise und
steht am Rand der Zahlungs
undfähigkeit dieser
Verfassungsbruch ist beispiellos in der
Geschichte
Deutschlands die Bürger
haben in dieser Lage nicht auf ihre
Regierungserklärung gewartet her Scholz
sondern auf ihre Rücktritts
erklär zwei Drittel der Deutschen wollen
dass diese Ampel endlich ein Ende nimmt
dass diese Regierung immer noch im Amt
ist zeigt ihre Missachtung für den
souveränen den Bürger sie haben genug
von einem Kanzler der sich mit
angeblichen Gedächtnislücken aus seiner
Verstrickung in ein der größten
steuerbetrugsskandale der Republik
herauswinden will Beweismittel schwinden
sie haben genug von einem ökonomischen
Analphabeten als Wirtschaftsminister der
die Wirtschaft zu Grunde richtet und die
bürgerüberhizungsdiktate
enteignet sie haben genug von einer
Außenministerin die 100.000 € im Jahr
für Styling ausgibt aber von einem
diplomatischen disaster ins nächste
stolpert sie haben genug das ist
wunderbar dass sie wieder aus der FDP da
rausbrüllen sie haben nämlich auch genug
von einem FDP
Finanzminister der verfassungswidrige
Haushalte verabschiedet um dieses grüne
Narrenschiff mitzufinanzieren und der
die Schuldenbremse abschaffen will und
sie haben genug von einer
Innenministerin die selbst das größte
Sicherheitsrisiko ist weil sie die
Grenzen und die Bürger nicht schützen
will diese Koalition regiert gegen die
Vernunft gegen die Wirklichkeit gegen
den
und das Wohl der Bürger und sie regiert
gegen unsere
Verfassung wir stecken in der tiefsten
Wirtschaftskrise seit es die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland gibt die
Deindustrialisierung ist im vollen Gange
ein insolvenzsunami nach dem anderen
rollt über unser
Land das ist ihr Werk das ist ihr Werk
ihres
planwirtschaftsministers und ihrer
hochsventionierten Energiewende und
Klimapolitik sie verteuern
Energie durch
Staatseingriffe verteilen dann
Subvention an Teile der Industrie
während sie den Mittelstand mit
horrenden Energiepreisen hängen lassen
und über CO2 Abgabe und
transportmauterhöhung zusätzlich die
Preise noch erhöhen diese Inter irale
führt direkt in die Verarmung
Unternehmen Normalverdiener und Rentner
bluten für ihre
Transformation sie brechen selbst ihr
Versprechen die Mehrwertsteuer für die
Gastronomie nicht wieder anzuheben damit
geben sie dem gasgewerbe den Todesstoß
ihr Bürgergeld treibt die sozialkrise
auf die Spitze die fleißigen werden
bestraft kein Wunder dass in ganzen
Branchen wertvolle Arbeit äfte aus der
Steuer und abgabenspirale in das
Bürgergeld flüchten bearbeitet ist der
Dumme wer arbeitet ist der dumme und
legt nicht mehr für sich und die Seinen
den rückenkrumm sondern für Abkassierer
aus aller Welt
62% der Familien im bürgergeldbezug
haben keinen deutschen Pass ihr
Bürgergeld ist ein
Etikettenschwindel es ist ein
migrantengeld ein
einwanderungsmagnet die
migrationskrise bringt unser Land an den
Rand des
Zusammenbruchs fast eine halbe Million
sozialmigranten allein dieses Jahr
rechnet man die asyler Erstanträge und
den Familiennachzug zusammen das kostet
uns nach den offiziellen Zahlen
50 Milliarden Euro jährlich sie bringen
diese Menschenmassen in Luxushotels
unter und Quartieren sie in Altenheim
während die Normalverdiener und Rentner
kaum noch über ihre Runden
kommen und trotzdem lassen sie die Tore
sperrangelweit offen und glauben sie
können das Volk durch wirkungslosen
Aktionismus noch einmal ruhig stellen
die Bürger aber spüren am eigenen Leib
dass die unkontrollierte
Masseneinwanderung in eine umfassende
sicherheitskrise geführt hat mehr
Deutsche als
Zuwanderer werden Opfer von tötungs
gewwalt und Rohheitsdelikten als
umgekehrt die Gewaltkriminalität
explodiert die Zahl der ausländischen
Straftäter auch für Frauen ist der
öffentliche Raum zum Risikogebiet
geworden dass sie lieber meiden mehr als
zwei brutale Gruppen Vergewaltigung am
Tag verzeichnet die
Kriminalstatistik was haben Sie da auf
unser Volk
losgelassen für den Verfall der inneren
Sicherheit tragen sie von der CDU und
CSU genauso die
Verantwortung und auf einmal empören Sie
sich über importierten islamischen
Judenhass als hätten sie eben erst
bemerkt dass es den gibt sie haben
hunderttausende junge Männer ins Land
geholt die in judenfeindlichen
gewaltbereiten Kulturen sozialisiert
sind sie lassen zu fundamental
Islamverbände einen Staat im Staate
bilden die Verantwortung für wachsenden
Antisemitismus haben sie mit Fake
Statistiken der einheimischen
Bevölkerung zugeschrieben ihr
plötzlicher Aktionismus ist heuchlerisch
solange sie weiter über den alltäglichen
deutschen feindlichen alltagsterror
gegen die einheimische Bevölkerung
schweigen die
Krise ist eine umfassende manifeste
Vertrauenskrise geworden ihre Politik
delegitimiert die demokratischen
Institution in den Augen der redlichen
Bürger sie tun so als hätte es das
vernichtende Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes überhaupt gar
nicht gegeben sie wollen auf diesen
Verfassungsbruch gleich den nächsten
Folgen lassen aber sie haben gar kein
Milliardenloch das ist lächerlich es ist
absurd in Anbetracht eine
rekordgesamtsteuereinnahme von ein
Billion
Euro das muss man sich mal vorstellen
eine Billionen Euro das heißt sie haben
nicht zu wenig sie haben
rekordgesamtsteuereinnahmen mit denen
sie gar nicht umgehen können wie alle
Sozialisten der Weg aus der Krise führt
über die Rückkehr zu Vernunft stoppen
Sie die Massenmigration indem sie die
Grenzen schließen und
einwanderungsmagneten wie
Bürgergeld Grundsicherung
passverramschung und Aufenthalt für alle
abschalten lösen Sie die Klimafonds auf
und beenden Sie das Milliardengrab
Energie und mobilitätswende es ist so
einfach verzichten Sie darauf Z
Milliarden in alle Welt zu verteilen für
ideologische Entwicklungshilfe
Klimaschutz in Indien und auch für die
Ukraine reduzieren Sie die Zahlung an
die EU und setzen Sie sich für eine
freiheitliche Reform der europäischen
Staatengemeinschaft ein dann bleibt auch
Geld für die Lösung der dringenden
Probleme in unserem Land Senkung der
Steuern und Abgaben Förderung von
Familien sichere Renten Sanierung des
Gesundheitssystems Wohnungsbau bessere
Schulen sichere Innenstädte und Grenzen
und eine funktionierende Armee sie aber
riskieren steuerkollaps Chaos und den
Staatsbankrott und darum brauchen wir
eine neue Regierung um aus diesem
krisensumpft heraus zu kommen darum
öffnen Sie den Weg für neue Wahlen und
erlösen Sie dieses Land von der
ampelregierung ich bedanke
mich der Bundestag debattiert hier nach
der Regierungserklärung des
Bundeskanzlers über die Situation Alis
Weidel war das äh eine die
Fraktionschefin der AFD und
Parteivorsitzende ist sie natürlich auch
noch Christian D ist der nächste Redner
er ein unparlamentarischen Zwischenruf
gegenüber der Abgeordneten Weid einen
Ordnungsruf erteilen reif Stegner von
der SPD hat hier ein Ordnungsruf
bekommen und noch mal Christian D ist
der Fraktionsvorsitzende der
fdpider weil ich es ungerne mache
ordnungsrufe zu verteilen schön wäre
wenn alle wenn alle sich in der Sache
streiten aber auf persönliche Angriffe
verzichten da hat die
bundisterspräsidentin völlig Richter
Zwischenruf kam jetzt von der Union
wieso leider für die fdpaktionner ist
ein Parteifreund von Frau Bars da wurde
wohl das falsche unterstellt Frau Bar
hat das völlig korrekt hier gehandab wie
ich finde Christian D den ich jetzt
schon dritte Mal angesagt habe hat jetzt
tatsächlich auch das Wort hier im
Parlament vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin
verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
hochverehrter Kollege März ich war ob
Teil ihrer Rede etwas überrascht sie
haben ja den
Bundeswirtschaftsministers vom glaube
grünen Parteitag zitiert mit dem Hinweis
die Union sei in den 90er Jahren stecken
geblieben ich teile die Auffassung des
Wirtschaftsministers aber darauf will
ich gar nicht hinaus sie haben sich
daraufhin ja diebisch gefreut dass die
wir Wirtschaftsminister der 90er jah
sozusagen ganz großartig gewesen sein
und ich will sie einfach nur darauf
hinweisen ein Wikipedia Nachschlag hätte
ausgereicht um festzustellen dass nicht
ein einziger Wirtschaftsminister der
90er Jahre von der cduc ist um gestellt
worden ist sondern ausschließlich von
FDP und SPD liebe Kollegin Kollegen
ausschließlich
also Lob nehmen wir an Lob nehmen wir an
aber man kann sich weiterentwickeln man
kann sich weiterentwickeln hochverehrte
Herr Merz und eins ist richtig der
Bundeskanzler hat es gerade gesagt das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat mit seinem
Urteil Klarheit über die Ausnahmen von
der Schuldenbremse und von
Sondervermögen geschaffen es hat im Kern
die Schuldenbremse im Grundgesetz
gestärkt und ich will deutlich sagen das
Urteil anders als es ihre Rede als ihre
Rede den Eindruck erweckt hat das Urteil
hat nicht eine Praxis dieser Regierung
beendet sondern eine Praxis auf Bundes
und Landesebene die von allen
politischen Akteuren verantwortet wurde
unabhängig von der parteifade und ich
will sehr selbstkritisch sagen
ein Teil der Praxis die das
Bundesverfassungsgericht geurteilt hat
hat auch diese Bundesregierung
fortgesetzt und das war im Nachhinein
ein Fehler aber die Tatsache dass das
nicht ausschließlich diese
Bundesregierung betrifft zeigt doch dass
der schlesig-holsteinische
Ministerpräsident Daniel Günther direkt
auf dieses Urteil regiert reagiert hat
und für das kommende Jahr und das
vergangene Jahr eine Notlage für den
Landeshaushalt in schleswiig-holstein
ausgerufen hat weil die Jährlichkeit
nicht gegeben war und ich will sie an
ihre eigene Regierungsverantwortung und
die Haushaltsberatung ich durfte damals
Teil des Haushaltsausschusses sein Herr
März erinnern das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat
richtigerweise auch gesagt es muss ein
Sachzusammenhang bestehen zwischen einer
notlagesituation und den Entscheidung
des haushaltsgesetzgebers und ich
erinner mich noch sehr gut an das
Konjunkturpaket ihrer Regierungszeit bei
allem Respekt liebe Kollegin Kollegen
der Union im Nachhinein muss man man
doch kritisch feststellen hatte der
stallumbau oder die nachhaltige
Waldbewirtschaftung wirklich etwas mit
der coronapandemie zu tun oder muss man
nicht im Nachhinein sagen auch das war
nicht rechtskonform diese Praxis
jedenfalls hat diese Bundesregierung nie
übernommen aus ihrer Regierungszeit
Liebe Kolleginen und
Kollegen ja wir hten die Frage der
Jährlichkeit und gerade bei
Sondervermögen früher beenden müssen das
sagen wir sehr selbstkritisch und es
sind für das laufende Haushaltsjahr
Änderung notwendig geworden der
Bundeskanzler hat das ausgeführt es sind
rechtliche Änderung und wichtig an
dieser Stelle ist dass wir am Freitag
einen Nachtragshaushalt beschließen
werden um nachträglich die richtigen und
notwendigen Strom- und gaspreisbremsen
abzusichern aber wichtig ist auch für
das Haushaltsjahr
2023 dass wir keine zusätzlichen
Schulden machen werden im Gegenteil es
wird uns mit dem Nachtragshaushalt 2023
gelegen die Nettokreditaufnahme des
Bundes um über 40% zu senken meine Damen
und Herren das ist gute Haushaltspolitik
liebe Kollegen
Kollegen und ich will etwas zur
Schuldenbremse an der Stelle sagen weil
ja dieses Urteil hat Rechtsklarheit
geschaffen aus der wir Konsequenzen
gezogen haben für den Bundeshaushalt 23
und wir werden diese auch ziehen für den
Bundeshaushalt 2024 und ich will
unumwunden einräumen mir ist bewusst
dass die Schuldenbremse im politischen
Raum unter Druck geraten ist Katharina
drögeer hat das ausgeführt sie hat vor
einige Ministerpräsidenten zitiert bei
den Menschen in Deutschland ist sie nach
wie vor richtigerweise beliebt und man
kann bei der Schuldenbremse politisch
unterschiedlicher Meinung sein und ja es
gibt auch innerhalb der Koalition
unterschiedliche Auffassung dazu aber
Herr März sich hier hinzustellen und
ernsthaft zu behaupten die unionsfamilie
sei an dieser Stelle geschlossen ist ja
wohl ein Witz schauen Sie nur auf diese
Bank und ich will erinnern an Hendrik
wüst an Daniel Günther an Kai Wegner an
Reiser haselof an Michael kretschm alle
diese unionsminister Präsidenten haben
bereits öffentlich erklärt dass sie
bereit sind die Schuldenbremse zu
schleifen der einzige der einzige meine
dam und Herren aus der Union der in
dieser Wochen die Schuldenbremse noch
nicht in Frage gestellt hat ist Markus
Söder aber meine Damen und Herren es ist
ja auch erst Dienstag liebe Kollegin
Kollegen
ich erwarte deshalb dass der wegruf aus
Karlsruhe so wie es das Bundeskabinett
sofort entschieden hat auch in den
Bundesländern ankommt und dass man das
Urteil entsprechend eins zu eins umsetzt
und deswegen will ich äh an der Stelle
in aller Klarheit sagen liebe Kolleg
Kollegen weil immer wieder in ihren
Reden ohne präzise zu werden Herr MZ ja
der Eindruck entwerkt dass hier ein
anderes finanzgebahn unterwegs sei das
stimmt z.B Bezug auf Sondervermögen
wissen Sie wie viel Sondervermögen zu
ihrer 16-jährigen Regierungszeit
gebildet worden sind es waren 15 diese
Bundesregierung schafft fünf
Sondervermögen ab wir schaffen
haushaltsklarheit und weit im Gegensatz
zu ihen lieber Kollege Merz im Gegensatz
zu
ihen
und ich will zum Schluss eines sagen ja
wir brauchen Zukunftsinvestition sie
sind notwendig um unsere Wirtschaft
Zukunft festzumachen wir stehen zu den
öffentlichen Investitionen in die
Infrastruktur beispielsweise der
bundesautobahnbau die Katharina dröer
angesprochen hat der Schienenausbau und
so weiter und soofort alles Investition
der öffentlichen Hand die unter ihn
vernachlässigt worden sind aber aber
gleichzeitig braucht es ein Puls für
private Investitionen in Deutschland
meine Damen und Herren um genau diese
zukunftsausgaben zu stellmen und
deswegen appelliere ich auch an der
Stelle an die staatspolitische
Verantwortung der CDU CSU ich kann nicht
nachvollziehen wieso sie aus taktischen
Gründen im Bundesrat das Wachstum
chancengesetetzt was unser Land so dring
braucht aufhalten geben Sie es endlich
frei damit diese Investitionen der
Privatwirtschaft möglich werden ich
danke
Ihnen mit dem wachstumschancengesetz im
Bundesrat ist momentan auch aufgehalten
dass die Steuer wieder erhöht wird in
der Gastronomie darüber wird jetzt also
diskutiert zwischen Bundestag und
Bundesrat Christian dgriff hier vor
allen Dingen auch Friedrich märz an und
sagte glauben Sie doch nicht dass die
Union geschlossen sei bei der Frage der
Schleifung der Schuldenbremse sein viele
Ministerpräsidenten der Meinung der
Regierung jetzt der Fraktionschef der
linkenlich der Geisel anschließen und
noch einmal die Aufforderung anschließen
dass die has möglichst umgehend alle
Geiseln sofort freilässt meine Damen und
Herren ich finde richtig dass der
Bundeskanzler hier heute eine
Regierungserklärung nach Aufforderung
der Opposition abgegeben hat das war
überfällig aber ich hätte mir sowohl
seitens des Kanzlers als auch seitens
der Redner der Regierungsfraktion etwas
mehr Demut erwartet denn die Realität
ist doch dass wir eine veritable
mindestens Regierungskrise haben ich
meine herr Scholz haben davon gesprochen
dass es nur
kon konturierungen gab aber ehrlich
gesagt wenn das denn so ist dann hätte
ich doch erwartet dass man mindestens
ein solches Urteil vorbereitet aber sie
waren völlig unvorbereitet auf dieses
Urteil das ist doch die Wahrheit völlig
unvorbereitet und das ist
unverantwortlich meine Damen und Herren
die Realität ist die Realität ist doch
Deutschland hat offensichtlich ein
Fachkräfteproblem mindestens bei
Finanzministern genau denn es war doch
Olaf Scholz der die glorreiche Idee
hatte die nicht genutzten coronahilfen
in den Klima und transformationsfond
umzuwidmen und Christian Lindner war es
der diesen Verfassungsbruch mit Ansage
durchgebunen hat beide beide sind
krachend gescheitert und sie tragen die
Verantwortung für die Regierungskrise
und für die Verunsicherung der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger und der
Unternehmen in diesem Land meine Damen
und Herren es ist doch es ist die
Süddeutsche Zeitung die von Trix rein
gesprochen hat es ist das Handelsblatt
was von Bilanzfälschung geredet hat es
ist der Spiegel der getitelt halt Olaf
Scholz vom Absturz eines besservices
nein meine Damen und Herren sie sind
keine Regierung von Format sie sind
keine Regierung die Probleme löst sie
schaffen mit ihrer unseriösen Politik
Probleme so kann man die viert stärkste
Industrienation der Welt nicht regieren
meine Damen und Herren die Wahrheit
heißt doch die Notlage des des Landes
heißt Ampel aber dagegen helfen eben
nicht einmal Kredite meine Damen und
Herren liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
machen wir uns nicht vor die
Schuldenbremse mit dieser Tage faktisch
von einem ihrer größten Fans zur Grabe
getragen nämlich von Christian Linder
habe jetzt verstanden dass Friedrich
Merz der nächste größte Fan ist in der
Union gibt's da aber offensichttig sehr
differenzierte Auffassung dazu ich
prophezeie mal sie werden auch 2024 die
Schuldenbremse aussetzen werden müssen
vielleicht liegt das ja auch daran dass
Herr Lindner den Wald vor lauter
Schattenhaushalten nicht mehr sehen kann
bringen sie Klarheit in ihre Finanzen
beenden Sie die Kakophonie die Wahrheit
ist nur eine völlig andere das Chaos
geht doch weiter wie ist denn das mit
den energiepreisbremsen in 5 Wochen
haben wir januar und die Realität ist
Christian Lindner sagt alles aus und
vorbei 5 Minuten später sagt Kevin küert
nein die werden beibehalten ja was ist
den nur die Wahrheit wie soll dann
unternehmerinen und Unternehmer planen
in dieser Situation sie tragen eine
Verantwortung genauso ist das mit den
Investitionen in die Chipfabriken was
ist denn da nur angesagt ich mein
Haselhoff sagt er hat mit dem Kanzler
telefoniert na Donnerwetter wenn das
ausreichend ist dann sind wir aber weit
in diesem Lande gekommen meine Damen und
Herren die Schuldenbremse ist eine
Investitionsbremse mit der
Schuldenbremse verfällt die
Infrastruktur was ist denn die Wahrheit
2009 wurde sie eingeführt und wie sind
denn jetzt wie ist denn jetzt die
Situation gibt es eine bessere Situation
bei der Bahn oder in den
Bildungseinrichtungen oder in den
Kliniken in den Straßen bei den Schienen
nicht davon wir brauchen Investition
nicht als Ausnahme sondern als Regel für
die nächsten Jahrzehnte meine Damen und
Herren ich meine Olaf Scholz hat doch
recht nur wenn sich Deutschland
modernisiert aber das sind Investitionen
doch die Voraussetzung wie soll ein Land
die gewaltigen Herausforderung der
notwendigen Transformation des
Klimaschutzes bewerkstelligen was nicht
einmal anständig investieren kann die
Schuldenbremse ist ein Anschlag auf die
Zukunft meine Damen und
Herren aber es geht natürlich nicht nur
um Investition sondern natürlich geht's
auch um Einnahmen und da meine ich
ausdrücklich nicht und wir meinen
ausdrücklich nicht mehr Einnahmen und
höhere Steuern etwa für die
hartarbeitende Mehrheit in diesem Land
nein im Gegenteil da müssen die
Belastung sogar runter bei steuern und
bei Strom aber es geht z.B um das
Streichen von Ausnahmen auf die größten
Erbschaften die sind die Erbschaften je
höher die Erbschaften desto niedriger
die Steuerlast also ich meine meine
Fraktion hat eine Anfrage stellt von den
40 Erben die über 100 Millionen 100
Millionen ich wiederhole vererbt haben
von den 40 haben 1 nicht ein Cent
Steuern gezahlt das ist doch ein Skandal
unser Land ist eine Steueroase für
Superreiche das muss man doch beenden
meine Damen und Herren das darf nicht so
bleiben und was machen sie real real
erhöhen sie die Mehrwertsteuer sie
erhöhen die Mehrwertsteuer für die
Restaurants und nehmen damit auch eine
Pleitewelle in Kauf das ist doch das ist
ist doch die Wahrheit ich meine sie
erhöhen auch die Mehrwertsteuer für
Schulessen z.B das ist im Übrigen ein
Skandal da sollten Sie mal auf
Kommunalpolitiker von linker bis Union
hören die da eine andere Position haben
sie haben im Wahlkampf was anderes
versprochen herr Scholz und sie lassen
jetzt auch die Diskussion um
Sozialleistung laufen auch in ihrer Rede
beenden Sie das doch und sagen sie ganz
klar es wird keine Sozialkürzungen
diesem Land geben das wäre so dringend
notwendig meine Damen und
Herren auch die FDP dann von
Ausgabenreduzierung spricht ja
einverstanden auch darüber kann man
reden aber sie haben ja bewusst einige
Bereiche vollständig rausgenommen und
das natürlich zuallererst der
Rüstungsbereich das der ist
offensichtlich sakang und das kann doch
nicht sein Verdopplung der Hilfe für die
Ukraine wird einfach mal so locker
zugesagt ich finde da sollte man mal ein
Fragezeichen setzen genauso wie bei der
Steigerung des verteidigungset letztlich
ist ihre Haushaltsplanung chaosp sie set
falsche Prioritäten sie schont die
vermögensten vermögsten das ist die
Wahrheit arbeiten sie endlich solide als
mit ungedeckten schcks auf Kosten der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger meine Damen und
Herren herzlichen
Dank dim der noch Fraktionschef der
Linksfraktion die heute fast komplett
anwesend ist hat noch mal die Hammers
aufgerufen alle Geiseln freizulassen er
hat gesagt ich hätte mir von der
Regierung mehr Demut erwartet sie tragen
Verantwortung
sie sind keine Regierung die Probleme
löst die Notlage des Landes heißt Ampel
dagegen hil noch nichtmals Kredite jetzt
Rolf
müzdaktion kgen es gibt nichts drum
herum zueden die Entscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts ist ein
deutlicher Rückschlag und auch für mich
eine
Ernüchterung und wenn ich das sage hat
das ganze auch eine Kehrseite ich habe
es ja vielleicht noch am ersten Tag
dass Freude oder Häme hier überwogen hat
bei denjenigen die Kläger gewesen waren
aber die zweite Frage die sich doch dann
direkt angeschlossen hat an dieses
Urteil war werden wir den
Herausforderung und Notwendigkeiten für
die Zukunft mit dieser HME und mit
dieser Freude überhaupt gerecht und ich
will sagen her Kollege märz die
Ministerpräsidentin Ministerpräsidenten
haben es früher erkannt offensichtlich
sie bis heute nicht ich bedauere
das weil der Spruch der Sproch hat
Folgen für alle für den Bund für die
Länder und damit auch indirekt für die
Kommunen und er hat für die Zukunft
dieses Landes mit Sicherheit seine
Folgen wir verkennen die Probleme nicht
aber ich finde auf der anderen Seite
gehört mit dazu aus einem Demokrat
Parlament zu sagen die Demokratie die
parlamentarische Demokratie wird es
schaffen aus diesen Problemen die
richtigen Schlussfolgerungen zu ziehen
das ist etwas was wir auch den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern Schulden und
insbesondere klarzustellen das ist kein
Staatsbankrott das ist kein
haushaltsnotstand bei uns werden keine
Behörden geschlossen bei uns werden die
Gehälter weiter ausgezahlt und wir
sollten uns nicht mit den bösen
Zeitgeistern mit den sprunghaften
Zeitgeistern ein konkurrenzwettkampf
leisten die Zeiten sind schlimm genug
und deswegen will ich durchaus sagen der
Populismus an dieser Stelle geht fehl
meine Damen und
Herren was heute von was heute von
Bedeutung ist was heute von Bedeutung
ist liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ist
nicht mehr aber auch nicht weniger meine
Fraktion hat es gestern getan ein
Nachtragshaushalts ein Antrag für den
Deutschen Bundestag beschlossen und
gleichzeitig auch die Ausnahmeregel die
das Grundgesetz bereiält erneut zu
aktivieren und ich kann nur sagen für
meine Fraktion wenn die Zeiten keine
normalen Zeiten sind und der
Bundeskanzler hat darauf hingewiesen
welche Herausforderung dieses Land
welchen Herausforderung die Welt
gegenüber steht wenn es keine normalen
Zeiten gibt dann kann es auch keinen
normalen Haushalt geben so wie man sich
das damals 2007 vorgestellt hat ich
finde schon dass wir politisch reagieren
müssen meine Damen und Herren und es
gibt
viele es gibt viele Gründe für das
Fortbestehen einer Beschreibung die eben
nicht normal ist hier ist oft der Krieg
in der Ukraine genannt worden und ich
gehe glaube ich nicht ganz fehl in der
Information dass die Bundesregierung am
11 Juni nächsten Jahres der Gastgeber
für die
wiederaufbaukonferenz für die Ukraine
sein wird einem Land was massiven
Angriffen von Seiten Russlands
ausgesetzt ist viele die dort vor Ort
sind berichten von Bildern die nicht nur
an den Ersten Weltkrieg heranreichen
sondern wahrscheinlich sogar schlimmere
Bilder sind die davon berichten dass
Städte massiv angegriffen werden und wer
wenn nicht wir die Demokratien stehen
nicht nur mit einer militärischen
Unterstützung an der Seite der Ukraine
sondern auch mit großen Leistungen was
die humanitäre Hilfe bedeutet und eben
auch für den Wiederaufbau das ist eines
der Gründe dass wir uns anstrengen
müssen in diesen nicht normalen Zeiten
auch haushaltig darauf zu reagieren und
jetzt kommt hinzu meine Damen und Herren
der Gazakrieg ja ich bin dankbar ich bin
der Bundesregierung für meine Fraktion
dankbar dass sie mit anderen Regierungen
aber insbesondere mit dem amerikanischen
Präsidenten aber auch mit dem
Generalsekretär der Vereinten Nationen
nichts unterlassen hat die Geiseln aus
der Hand der herass zu befreien und wer
glaubt plötzlich wird diese Situation
ganz einfach werden ich glaube der trügt
weil diejenigen die Israel vernichten
wollen schauen sich ganz genau an was
die Hamas jetzt in diesen Stunden macht
sie hat ohnehin der PLO bereits den Rang
abgelaufen was den Widerstand bedeutet
und irgendwann sind wir nicht sicher ob
nicht doch aus diesem Gazakrieg auch ein
Flächenbrand wird die ersten Dinge die
da aus dem Jemen in Richtung Israel
gegangen sind die konnten noch abgewehrt
werden aber was heißt es denn wenn die
Meerenge vor der jemenitischen Küste
geschlossen wird nicht nur für Europa
sondern auch für Asien ich schließe
daraus dass wir noch unabhängiger werden
müssen und ich glaube es gibt viele
Gründe die eben für das für diese
Ereignisse die Kontrolle des Staates
entzogen worden sind und damit auch die
staatliche Finanzlage so nicht mehr
unter Kontrolle ist und deswegen glaube
ich war richtig gewesen mit dem Antrag
den wir in dieser in dieser Woche in den
Deutschen Bundestag einbringen auch von
Artikel 115 wieder Gebrauch zu machen
und Herr märz und liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen darauf lässt sich argumentieren
ihr Kollege der Ministerpräsident
Günther tut das frei Weg in
Schleswig-Holstein genau auf diese
Gründe bezogen und da trifft er auf eine
Opposition die eben für die notwendige
zwei Drittel Mehrheit eben verhilft
damit diese Notlage auch beschrieben
werden kann deswegen wird auf sie wird
auf sie durchaus und überlegen Sie es
sich gut ob sie den Menschen im Atal und
wir müssen den Artikel 100 wir müssen
den Artikel
115 für diese Hilfen ziehen überlegen
Sie gut ob Sie die Hilfen für die
Menschen im Atal in rheinernfalz und in
nochin Westfalen ablehen hier im
deutschen
Bundestag und zum anderen und zum
anderen wenn wir heute über das
verfassungsgerichtsordteil sprechen
sprechen wir auch über den Haushalt
2024 wir als SPD
Bundestagsfraktion haben die klare
Absicht noch in diesem Jahr auch diesen
Haushalt zu verabschieden aus zwei
Gründen und vielleicht reicht ihn ja der
Eine Grund nicht für uns ist aber
wichtig dass insbesondere die sozialen
Verbände die unter Kürzungen des
Haushaltsentwurfs gelitten haben und die
in der Bereinigungssitzung wieder
korrigiert worden sind noch in diesem
Jahr Planungssicherheit haben weil sonst
müssen sie eben Mitarbeiterin und
Mitarbeiter entlassen ich finde das ist
ein guter Grund und zum anderen das
Budgetrecht des Parlaments ist das
vornehmste Recht des Deutschen
Bundestages vielleicht könnten auch sie
mit überlegen ob wir uns das nicht
sichern sollten als Parlament deswegen
bitte ich dass wir den Haushalt
2024 rechtzeitig vor Ende des Jahres
abschließen uns das uns den Respekt
erweisen aber insbesondere den Menschen
draußen im Lande weil die brauchen die
Sicherheit auch aus diesem Haushalt
meine Damen und Herren und zum anderen
und das bedarf diese
debte finde ich auch ja und das sagen
wir schon seit Jahren wir brauchen
grundsätzliche Korrekturen an der
Gestaltung der
Schuldenbremse wir müssen uns noch
fragen ob sie angemessen ist vor den
Herausforderungen dieser Zeit die mehr
als 15 Jahre ins Land gegangen sind das
ist auch Aufgabe der Politik nicht
irgendwas sakrosant zu machen sondern
immer wieder sagen reicht es aus für die
Zukunft unseres Landes oder hat nicht
sogar die Schuldenbremse diese
Haushaltsführung provoziert vielleicht
darf man ja diese Frage auch mal stellen
und offensichtlich leiden ja auch die
einen oder anderen Ländern da drunter
aber ich meine Damen und Herren kann nur
empfehlen eine wahlos gegriffene
politische Größe nicht als monstrans vor
sich herzuführen wenn es um die Zukunft
dieses Landes geht dieses Land hat etwas
anderes verdient nämlich in Zukunft zu
investieren und nicht meine Damen und
Herren in die Vergangenheit ja und es
ist gesagt worden das ist nicht alles
aber wir brauchen meine Damen und Herren
einen aktiven Staat andere Länder und
ich will Demokratien zitieren die dies
mit Ehrgeiz auf den Weg bringen und mit
Modernität liegen mittlerweile
meilenweit Deutschland Voraus nicht nur
in den Investitionen sondern im
Gründergeist und wo sie eben auch
Industrie industrielle Kapazitäten aus
Europa abziehen die USA ist hier genannt
worden aber ich will auch Spanien nennen
Großbritannien hat erst vorgestern 5
Milliarden Euro in die
batteriefertigung investiert und
deswegen will ich sehr klar sagen ich
glaube es ist richtig auch für den
nächsten Haushalt für den mit Artikel
115 davon Gebrauch zu machen wir
brauchen meine Damen und Herren diese
Zukunftsinvestition zum
anderen um auch mal einer
Geschichtsklitterung
vorzubeugen der Fond oder die Fonds und
mein Kollege hat ja beschrieben wie
lange es schon mit diesen Fonds im
Bundeshaushalt ist ist nicht die
Erfindung einer Person und deswegen sage
ich auch sehr deutlich andere zum
Sündenbock zu machen werde ich nicht
akzeptieren der Staatssekretär Werner
Gatzer hat nicht mehr aber auch nicht
weniger gemacht als das was politisch
gewollt ist meine Damen und Herren
technisch umzusetzen ich finde ich finde
das gehört zur Wahrheit mit
dazu und zum anderen wen
über diese Geschichte reden dann will
ich auch hier gegenüber der
Öffentlichkeit sagen ich zumindestens
kann mich gut daran erinnern dass in den
Haushalts in den
Koalitionsverhandlungen gerade vor dem
Hintergrund des
hässischen
Verfassungsgerichtsurteils genau über
diese Schritte gesprochen worden sind
und ich finde politische Verantwortung
gibt man nicht am Kleiderhaken auf
sondern dazu steht man meine Damen und
Herren und deswegen sage es auch noch
mal dies zumindestens vielleicht
interessiert hier wird ja vieles ganz
schwarz an die Wand gemalt was mit
diesem Land mit Deutschland verbunden
ist wir sind das Land was in Europa mit
die geringste Schuldenquote hat
62% 20% unter dem Durchschnitt der der
europäischen Länder
30% unter demem der Euroländer ich finde
schon das müssen sie akzeptieren zahlen
lügen einfach nicht da können sie sich
nicht gegen wehren und deswegen ich
glaube dass in dieser Situation etwas
vertretbar ist aber damit es Ihnen
vielleicht noch besser gefällt und damit
auch die politische Auseinandersetzung
endlich mal in diesem Parlament zwischen
uns auch klar wird es geht nicht um
verfassungstechnische Fragen sondern es
geht darum Verteilungsfragen auch in
diesem Land immer wieder zu adressieren
deswegen sage ich auch klar ja wir
müssen über einen verfassungsgemäßen
Haushalt reden aber auf der anderen
Seite auch über unverdienten Reichtum in
diesem Land und wir SozialdemokratInnen
Sozialdemokraten werden in einer Woche
auf dem Bundesparteitag genau die
richtigen Antworten auf diesen
Herausforderung geben meine Damen und
Herren es ist kein
Zweifel es ist kein Zweifel wir werden
dieses Urteil umsetzen ich habe Respekt
vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht aber
ich will auch gleichzeitig sagen ich
hoffe auch dass das
Bundesverfassungsgericht vor anderen
verfassungsinstitutionen wie dem
Deutschen Bundestag auch Respekt hat
deswegen finde ich wenn man uns wenn man
sich gegenseitig Respekt erlaubt kann
man über das eine oder andere auch
diskutieren ich bin mir unsicher ob die
kameralistische und strenge Auslegung
von Jährlichkeit und jährigkeit wirklich
den Herausforderungen gerecht wird meine
Damen und Herren jeder Investor jeder
Investor in diesem Land plant glaube ich
länger als ein Jahr soziale Verbände
sind darauf angewiesen dass ihre Arbeit
länger als ein Jahr dauert und schon gar
nicht Naturkatastrophen halten sich an
die jährlich und jährigkeit sondern sie
und das zeigt ja z.B das atil was diese
Herausforderung sind deswegen will ich
sagen manche Argumentation
erschließt sich mir nicht und
insbesondere die
haushaltsverfassungsrechtliche Dogmatik
in Übereinstimmung mit einem
Richterspruch zu bringen der uns vor
einigen Jahren den Klimaschutz als
Verfassungsrang definiert hat hätte ich
mir von diesem
Teil meine Damen und Herren schon
erwartet und das 2007 dasselbe
Bundesverfassungsgericht uns auch
Anleitung zur Schuldenbremse gegeben hat
dass ist ja auch Teil der Wahrheit aber
was mir am meisten aufgestoßen ist und
ich finde das gehört zu einer
öffentlichen Debatte dazu einmal kann
das passieren wenn man sich einen
langfristigen Zeitplan gibt damals als
es um das gebäudeenergiegesetz ging und
als wir es kurz vor der Sommerpause im
Interesse der Menschen hier abschließend
lesen wollen gab es das Teil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes auch jetzt
wieder ein Tag vor der
Bereinigungssitzung mit diesem Urteil zu
Konf er zu werden provoziert auch manche
Diskussion auch in meinen Reihen und
auch das meine Damen und Herren müssen
die Richterinnen und Richter wissen
deswegen zum Schluss ich habe ich habe
ich habe den ich habe ich habe den
Respekt gegenüber dem
Bundesverfassungsgericht geäußert aber
ich will auch sagen ich glaube auch dass
der Deutsche Bundestag Respekt
verlangt meine Damen und Herren
der 24 sollte rechtzeitig beschlossen
werden ich finde in der
Bereinigungssitzung ist Beachtliches
geleistet worden darüber wird
hoffentlich in den kommenden Wochen noch
im Deutschen Bundestag ausreichend
gesprochen werden aber ich will einen
Punkt herausgreifen den der Kinder und
Jugendpolitik der Kinder und jugendplan
ist verbessert worden die
Elterngeldregelung ist verbessert worden
wir haben Mittel für die bfkreform auf
den Weg gebracht aber was mir ganz
wichtig war dass auch die Förderung des
Sports für junge Menschen mit
Behinderung Eingang in diesen Haushalt
gefunden hat und da will ich ganz klar
sagen weil wir reden manchmal über
Verfassungs Technik für die
Haushaltsführung hier geht's konkret um
junge Menschen mit Behinderung und das
meine Damen und Herren ist die
haushalterische Antwort auf einen
Skandal der leider viel zu schnell
vergessen worden ist der vom
chefpropagandisten der AFD von Herrn
höcke im Sommer diesen Jahres in die
Welt gebracht worden ist dass nämlich
junge Menschen mit Behinderung die
geboren sind oder durch einen Unfall
diese Behinderung davon tragen oder
durch Krankheit eine Belastung für diese
Gesellschaft sind was für ein Skandal
meine Damen und Herren und deswegen sage
ich hinter einem
Haushalt em Haushalt stehen auch
politische Antworten und deswegen sage
ich auch denen die da meinen und das
spreche ich niemandem ab die Wahl ist
frei aber wer sich den Luxus leistet
eine solche Partei in die Macht zu
bringen der muss sich nicht wundern dass
es nicht nur bei diesen Kindern und
Jugendlichen bleibt sondern dann sind
die Kranken dran dann sind die
Rentnerinnen und Rentner dran dann sind
die Mens die so fühlen auch so leben
wollen dran das ist die Konsequenz und
das ist auch in einer Haushaltsdebatte
erforderlich meine Damen und Herren
deswegen sage ich ohne soziale
Gerechtigkeit und Anstand kann man eine
freiheitliche Demokratie nicht bestehen
deshalb entscheiden wir in diesen Tagen
nicht allein über ein angepasstes Budget
und über dessen verfassungsrechtliche
vorauss es geht nicht allein um
finanztechnische Fragen in diesen Tagen
entscheiden wir auch über ein
verlässliches Maß an sozialer
Gerechtigkeit für Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer deren Familien junge
Menschen Kranke wir entscheiden über die
Bollwerke einer lebensfähigen sozialen
Demokratie meine Damen und her vielen
Dank Rolf müzenich ein selbstbewuser
Sozialdemokrat der Führer der SPD
Fraktion hat hier noch mal dargestellt
dass die Entscheidung des
wachstungsgericht ein deutlicher
Rückschlag gewesen sein wenn die Zeiten
keine normalen Zeiten sind dann kann es
auch keine normalen Haushalte geben ich
finde schon dass wir politisch reagieren
müssen er hat dann ausgeführt was er
damit meint unter anderem sieht er dass
die Schuldenbremse auch für 2024 noch
einmal ausgesetzt werden muss das
erklärt auch warum die Sozialdemokraten
von Anfang an behauptet haben der
Haushalt 2024 könne noch in diesem Jahr
dann verabschiedet werden mal sehen der
beim Bundeskanzler Klang ist heute etwas
anders die FDP hat auch eine andere
Meinung mal schauen wie wie es kommt
aber Rolf mützenig Schute sich auch
nicht das Bundesverfassungsgericht zu
kritisieren obwohl er Respekt vor dem
BVG hat hat er gesagt kommen die
Entscheidungen die beim heizungsgesetz
ständig kurz vor der eigentlichen
Entscheidung des Bundestages und
erfderte als selbstbewusster
Parlamentarier hier auch Respekt für den
Deutschen Bundestag ein Alexander dobr
jetzt der landesgruppenchef der CD CSU
Kolleginnen und
Kollegen politische Verantwortung gibt
man nicht am Kleiderhaken ab dazu steht
man Herr Mütze nicht das waren ihre
Worte gerade genau das hätten wir heute
an diesem Rednerpult erwartet es gab
kein Wort das bedauern es gab keine
Entschuldigung dieser ampelregierung
meine Damen und
Herren Herr Bundeskanzler sie haben
heute dem Deutschen Bundestag und der
Öffentlichkeit mitgeteilt dass die
anwendungs Regeln der Schuldenbremse vor
diesem
Verfassungsgerichtsurteil nicht wirklich
bekannt gewesen wären sie haben weiter
der Öffentlichkeit und im Bundestag
mitgeteilt dass
das Verfassungsgericht über eine
Staatspraxis geurteilt hätte und sie
haben ferner Herr mützenig auch noch die
Dreistigkeit besessen davon zu reden
dass die Schuldenbremse vielleicht sogar
diesen Betrug provoziert hätte ich will
ihnen sag wie die Realität an dieser
Stelle ist diese Worte diese Worte von
ihnen Staatspraxis nicht bekannt wie die
Schuldenbremse wirkt und dann auch noch
zu behaupten dass es vielleicht die
Grundlage für den Betrug ist das zeigt
die ganze Arroganz und Respektlosigkeit
wie sie mit diesem Urteil
umgehen es war ihre ampelregierung her
die Sie zu verantworten haben die sich
Milliarden vorratsschulden in den Keller
gelegt hat die sich nach Belieben über
Zeitpunkt und Zweck der Ausgaben dieser
schuldengelder selber entscheiden wollte
und die alle Welt glauben machen wollte
dass sie die Schuldenbremse einhalten
obwohl jetzt klar ist mit dem
nachtagshaushalt dass sie 45 Milliarden
über die Schuldenbremse ausgegeben haben
und deswegen hat die Süddeutsche natür
recht wenn sie am Wochenende titelt die
Tricker das ist das Prädikat ihrer Ampel
und ich sage es sind nicht nur Tricker
sondern es ist schlichtweg der Betrug an
der Schuldenbremse der hier begangen
worden
ist und jetzt haben wir heute wieder
gehört dass wie ein Mantra das ständig
vor sich hergetragen wird dass es ja
auch in der Vorgängerregierung schon
einen V mit überjährigkeit gegeben hat
der in den Haushalt eingestellt worden
ist was sie dabei was sie dabei aber
verschweigen ist erstens dass dieser
vond hatte nicht ihre buchungstricks um
die Schuldenbremse zu übergehen und
zweitens dass der
Bundesfinanzminister zu diesem Zeitpunkt
Olaf Scholz geheißen hat und deswegen
hat das Verfassungsgericht nicht über
eine Staatspraxis entschieden sondern
das hat über das System Olaf Scholz
entschieden und das Kraft
gesetzt sie haben dabei übrigens alle
Warnungen außer Acht gelassen alle
Warnungen die auch jetzt in den letzten
Tagen ja wiederholt worden sind der
persönliche Berater des Finanzministers
Professor Lares Feld hat es noch mal
deutlich gesagt wörtlich zitiert trotz
der Bedenken im
Bundesfinanzministerium vor und nach dem
im amtsbeginn der Bundesregierung kam es
zu dieser Entscheidung der
Stabilitätsrat hat sie explizit damals
darauf hingewiesen wörtlich zitiert
damit droht dass das
verfassungsrechtliche Ziel der
Schuldenbremse faktisch ausgehölt wird
Warnungen gab es genug sie wollten sie
ignorieren sie wollten sie schlichtweg
ignorieren und auch das sagt das Urteil
es ist schlichtweg die ganz die sie am
Schluss dazu gebracht hat dass sie die
Verfassung gebrochen haben meine Damen
und
Herren und Herr Bundeskanzler sie haben
heute mit keinem Wort erwähnt wie unsere
europäischen Nachbarn über diese
Finanzkrise in Deutschland denken die
Menschen allerdings haben einen sehr
klaren Eindruck davon bekommen was sich
in unserem Land verändert hat dass beim
Besuch der italienischen
Ministerpräsidentin hier in Berlin bei
ihrem gemeinsamen Auftritt die
italienische Ministerpräsidentin von
Journalisten gefragt wird im Bezug auf
ihre Finanzfragen ob da Deutschland noch
ein verlässlicher Partner ist das hätten
sich die Menschen in unserem Land
niemals vorstellen können das berührt
die Menschen und das meine dam zeigt die
ganze Verzweiflung in der Sie diese
Bundesregierung gebracht
haben
in Europa werden aktuell die
Verhandlungen über ein gemeinsamen
Haushalt geführt der Stabilitäts und
Wachstumspakt der wird auch neu
verhandelt werden die Akzeptanz über das
Einhalten von Regeln spielt dabei eine
ganz entscheidende Rolle und wir haben
das in der Vergangenheit schon mal
erlebt denken sie zurück an die
eurofinanzkrise was wir da erlebt haben
die Finanzstabilität und Solidität
Deutschlands die hat die gemeinsame
Währung zusammengehalten Deutschland war
es die den Euro am Schluss gerettet
haben wenn die Haushaltsregeln in
Deutschland nicht mehr eingehalten
werden dann wird es schwer in Europa
unsere Partner zur
Haushaltsdisziplin zu bewegen das heißt
her Bundeskanzler mit ihrer Politik
gefährden sie die Finanzstabilität in
Europa das ist die Wahrheit
ich hätte heute übrigens erwartet dass
sie ein klares Bekenntnis abgeben Herr
Bundeskanzler dass sie die
Schuldenbremse 2024 einhalten wollen ich
hätte dieses klare Bekenntnis erwartet
weil es ein paar andere verstörende
Wortmeldungen der hier gegeben hat Herr
Mützenich ich habe sehr genau aufgepasst
sie haben mehrfach die die Ukraine in
ihrer Rede erwähnt sie haben mehrfach
von unnormalen Zeiten gesprochen das ist
doch nichts anderes als dass sie
vorbereiten wollen dass
2024 die Schuldenbremse auch nicht mehr
eingehalten wird und ich will ihn damit
auf die Reise geben bei ihren Beratungen
wir werden auf absehbare Zeit keine
normalen Zeiten mehr erleben wer das als
Ausrede nimmt der wird nie wieder zu
Haushalten zurückfüren meine Damen und
Herren und anstatt dass sie dem
Bundestag und der Öffentlichkeit
mitteilen wie sie die Schuldenbremse
2024 einhalten können sind weite Teile
ihrer Koalition jeden Tag damit
beschäftigt darüber zu diskutieren wie
man die Schuldenbremse abschaffen kann
oder wie man die Schuldenbremse
aufweicht kan das ist schlichtweg kein
Bekenntnis zum Einhalten der
Schuldenbremse und der Regeln wir haben
am Parteitag wir haben am Parteitag der
Grünen Herrn habeg auch sehr genau
zugehört der formuliert hat mit der
Schuldenbremse ein Zitat mit der
Schuldenbremse haben wir uns freiwillig
die Hände auf den Rücken gefesselt und
ziehen in einen Boxkampf nur mal hier zu
den Fakten in diesem Jahr 20
23 ist es möglich mit Einhalten der
Schuldenbremse legal über 40 Milliarden
Euro neue Schulden zu machen im nächsten
Jahr ist es legal beim Einhalten der
Schuldenbremse möglich über 20
Milliarden neue Schulden zu machen sie
wollen einfach nicht mit diesem Geld
zurechtkommen für sie reicht dieses Geld
schlichtweg einfach nicht aus und
deswegen sage ich Ihnen Herr habbeck die
Ampel ist doch kein Boxer dem man die
Hände gefesselt hat die Ampel ist ein
schuldensüchtiger dem bei der
Beschaffungskriminalität entdeckt
erwischt
hat wissen Sie die Schuldenbremse wurde
doch genau deswegen eingeführt um so
eine Politik zu verhindern die
Schuldenbremse wurde doch genau deswegen
eingeführt um vorzubeugen Politik
ausschließlich auf Kosten der kommenden
Generation gemacht worden ist die Schuld
gemacht wird die Schuldenbremse soll
doch schlichtweg verhindern dass die
Ausgaben ins Uferlose wachsen sie soll
disziplinieren das ist doch schlichtweg
die Aufgabe der Schuldenbremse und
deswegen sage ich Ihnen auch an dieser
Stelle sie können mit uns
selbstverständlich darüber reden wie man
solide Haushalte aufstellt aber wir
reichen keine Hand dafür unsolides
Haushalten in dieser Bundesregierung zum
Dauerbeschäftigung zu machen wir geben
ihnen nicht die Hand dafür dass die
abschaffen der Schuldenbremse
legalisiert wird dafür haben sie nicht
unsere
Unterstützung so wir waren jetzt auch
überrascht zu hören dass Sie Herr
mützinig den Haushalt
2024 noch in diesem Jahr beraten wollen
es hat gestern ein Schreiben des
bundesfanzministers der hat in diesem
Schreiben an alle Kolleginnen und
Kollegen darauf hingewiesen dass er den
Haushalt 24 gemeinsam mit dem Haushalt
25 beraten will das riecht nicht danach
dass das in diesem Jahr noch stattfinden
kann möglicherweise sind auch sie hier
nicht einig und möglicherweise sind sie
auch hier nicht in der Lage eine
gemeinsame Linie zu finden ich kann ihn
an der Stelle nur sagen das was der Bund
des Finanzminister in der letzten
Debatte hier formuliert hat Bildung
Sicherheit Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
wörtliches Zitat all das ist möglich bei
den bestehenden Einnahmen ohne Flucht in
neue Schulden oder höhere Steuern Herr
Bundesfinanzminister wir nehmen sie
schlichtweg hier beim Wort dieses Land
hat kein
Einnahmeproblem es hat schlichtweg ein
ausgabeproblem das heißt setzen sie
endlich
setzen Sie den Sparstift an dieses Land
braucht schlichtweg kein heizunggesetz
das dem Staat und Bürger Milliarden
kostet es braucht keine 5000 neuen
Sacharbeiter stellen um die
Kindergrundsicherung auszubezahlen und
es braucht kein Bürgergeld dass die
Menschen die sozialhilel treibt und
nicht in die Arbeit integriert das
braucht dieses Land
nicht
und sehr Gehrer
Bundeskanzler dass sie das Wort des
Bedauerns und der Entschuldigung hier
nicht in der Lage waren gegenüber der
Öffentlichkeit und dem Bundestag zum
Ausdruck zu bringen das empfinde ich
schlichtweg als nicht angemessen ich
empfinde das nicht als angemessen und
ich kann ihn sagen dieses Land braucht
Führung und keine Phrasen zeigen sie
Führung und beenden sie endlich dieses
ampeldrama herzlichen Dank
Alexander dobrin der vorne und hinten in
seiner Reg Rede darauf hinwies dass
diese Bundesregierung sich nicht
entschuldigt haben für das Finanzielle
disaster was jetzt droht es se ein
Betrug an der Schuldenbremse wir geben
ihn nicht die Hand dafür dass die
Abschaffung die Abschaffung des der
Schuldenbremse in diesem Land
durchgeführt wird das werden wir nicht
mitstimmen jetzt also s chisan Kindler
von den Bündnisgrünen her drin das Wand
brauch Führung keine Phrasen das hat
ihre Rede sehr gut ausgezeichnet und
zusammengefasst und ich hätte mir ja
auch ein bisschen mehr Demut gewünscht
wenn ich ihr rede gehört habe angesichts
der Maut die Sie beschlossen haben aber
das ist vielleicht eine Stilfrage die
uns von ih
unterscheidet Herr März Herr März ich
wollte was zu ihrer Rede sagen sie haben
sich als Mann der 90er Jahre geautet
jetzt gehen sie nach hinten aber ich
wollte trotzdem noch noch mal
eingehen ich finde ja gut dass sie dazu
stehen dass Mann 90er Jahre sind ich
find es gut wenn man sich selbst steht
wollte darauf Hinweisen darauf hat auch
der FDP Kollege schon hingewiesen Herr
dur ich bin sehr froh dass der heutige
Wirtschaftsminister Robert habbeck heißt
und Jürgen Möllemann um das klar zu
sagen se hart für die FDP aber ich
glaube da gibt's einen breiten Kons in
diesem
Haus und in den 90er Jahren Herr März
waren sie schon im Bundestag ich war in
der Grundschule aber ich habe damals
schon aufgepasst wie die
finanzpolitischen Rahmendaten waren und
ich will sie noch mal erinnern wie das
war war Finanzminister die
Staatsschulden in Deutschland 600
Milliarden 600 Milliarden Deutsche Mark
DMark auf 1,45 Milliarden DMark
gestiegen 850 Milliarden DMark die
statschonen von 1990 bis 1998 gestiegen
es gab eine Vermögenssteuer noch in
Deutschland in den 90er Jahren die hat
Weige sogar erhöht es gab ein
Solidaritätsbeitrag der
spitzensteuersachs lag lag be 53% und
die Schuldenbremse war nicht im
Grundgesetz ich finde spannend dass S
diesen finanzpolitischen Rahmendaten
orientieren wollen das das vorbit nehmen
ich bin gespannt auf ih Initiativen dazu
in der nächsten Zeit Herr
märz und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
das bundesverfassungsricht hat uns einen
klaren Auftrag gegeben und ich will hier
sehr klar sagen das war ein Fehler der
zweite Nachtragshaushalt 21 darum kann
man nicht drum rumreden und gleichzeitig
hat es aber massive Auswirkung für die
Staatshaushalte in Bund und Ländern
aktuell hat gerade reiner Haselhoff per
Deutsche Presseagentur erklärt dass er
sonderver mögen dass in Corona
aufgenommen haben notlagenkrediten dafür
2023 und 2024 die Notlage erklären
werden genauso macht es dan Günter CDU
Ministerpräsident in schlesäigholstein
der Landtag hat es beschlossen 2023 2024
die Notlage erklärt das heißt wir haben
noch eine gemeinsame Verantwortung jetzt
auf Grundlage dieses Urteils darf man
sich nicht wegducken muss man der
Verantwortung auch stehen als
Union und ich glaube das unterscheidet
eben Friedrich März und die
Oppositionsfraktion der hier im
Deutschen Bundestag von den
Regierungspolitikern die in
Verantwortung stehen die CDU
ministerpridenten und andere Politiker
Verantwortung müssen sich eben konkrete
Gedanken machen wie wir zukünftig
Haushalte aufstellen das machen Kai
Wegner das machen reiner Haselhoff das
macht Michael kretschm das macht Henrik
wüst die ja alle darüber gesprochen
haben dass sie ein Modernisierungsbedarf
bei der Schuldenbremse sehen weil sie
sich die Frage stellen wie können wir in
Zukunft e noch Investitionen finanzieren
oder nach diesem
Urteil und es ist stellt sich eben die
Frage wie können wir jetzt es hilft der
nächsten Generation noch nichts wenn dur
Schulen Z die Decke tropft es hilft der
nächsten Generation nichts wenn die
Infrastruktur verrottet wenn
Eisenbahnbrücken gesperrt werden müssen
nicht mehrfahren werden können es hilft
der nächsten Generation nichts wenn die
klimaneutrale Transformation der
Wirtschaft jetzt gestoppt wird und
deswegen müssen wir darüber reden wie
wir diese Investition in Zukunft
finanzieren können und Wirtschaft
wirtschaftspolitisch wä es auch sinnvoll
sich ein Unternehmen zu investieren
jedes große jedes kleine jedes
mittelständ Unternehmen finanziert
Investitionen nicht nur aus Eigenkapital
nicht nur aus laufenden Einnahmen sie
finden Fremdkapital anders gesagt über
Kredite über Schulden weil es eben
nachhaltige Investitionen geht so
werthaltige Investitionen geht die neues
Vermögen schaffen deswegen machen das
Unternehmen wir müssen über reden wie
wir im Rahmen der Schuldenbremse die wir
nicht abschaffen wollen aber die wir
erweitern wollen die wir öffnen wollen
für Investition jetzt wieder Investition
schaffen wir freuen uns auf Vorschläge
aus der CDU wir freuen uns auf
Vorschläge CDU
Ministerpräsidenten und ich will jetzt
klar sagen es geht beim den 60
Milliarden jetzt im KTF geht es um
Klimaschutz es geht um die Einhaltung
von Gesetzen es geht die Einhaltung von
Abkommen das völkerrechtie Pariser
Klimaabkommen es geht um das
Klimaschutzgesetz und es geht Kern der
Generationengerechtigkeit dass unsere
Kinder unser Enkel noch eine Zukunft wie
Planeten haben darum geht es beim
klimaransformationsfond aber es geht
gleichzeitig auch darum bei den 60
Milliarden Euro um die Zukunft der
deutschen Wirtschaft es geht darum wie
wir grün Star schaffen können wie wir
die Chemieindustrie umbauen können wie
wir die Zementindustrie umbauen können
es geht darum dass solarproduktion es
geht um die windkraftproduktion D nicht
nur in USA und China stattfindet sondern
dass sie in Deutschland stattfindet es
geht darum dass batteriezellenproduktion
in Deutschland in schleswiig-holstein
stattfindet es geht darum dass wir die
Gebäudesanierung
organisieren und finanzieren es geht um
die mobilitätswende und zwar überall in
Deutschland in Sachsen in Sachsen-Anhalt
in Brandenburg in schlesig-holschland im
Saarland in Bremen NW überall es geht um
10000 100000 Arbeitsplätze die wir nicht
gefährden dürfen und deswegen haben wir
eine gemeinsame Verantwortung das jetzt
langfristig zu finanzieren diese gemeins
Verantwortung haben wir alle die
Bundesregierung die Koalition hier im
Parlament die demokratische Opposition
und die Landesregierung diese gemein
Verantwortung müssen wir jetzt annehmen
danke als nächst hat das Wort für die
AFD Fraktion
frau Präsidentin wir erleben historische
Wochen die Rechtsbrüche und
Fehlentscheidungen von Jahren
kulminieren in einer Haushaltskrise
hinter der sich eine Regierungs und auch
eine vernunftkrise verbirgt die
Schlussfolgerung des Kanzlers aus einem
zwingenden Urteil des
Verfassungsgerichts sind abwegig und
unlogisch die Regierung kann nicht
rückwirkend für 2023 die Fortdauer einer
unkontrollierbaren Notsituation
behaupten nachdem sie selbst diese 2022
für beendet erklärt hatte es geht
nicht man durfte gespannt sein ob
diesmal über eine energienotlage
begründet werden würde oder über Kriege
im Ausland oder über erneut
aufflammendes Corona wüten oder über die
unmittelbare der erdüberhitzung wir
haben s eben gehört von Herrn Kindler
oder vielleicht eine Sturmflut wie sie
vorige Woche in Schleswig-Holstein als
notstandsbegründung bereits für 2024
herhalten musste gestern Abend kam dann
nun die Auflösung der Krieg von Februar
22 und sogar die arilfut von
2021 sind die Schuldigen an der Not
2023 all das
entdeckten sie direkt nach dem Urteil
und ganz plötzlich im November 23
rückwirkend für J auf welch peinlichem
Niveau sollen wir hier noch getäuscht
werden diese Begründung diese Begründung
den Bundestag zur Abstimmung zuzumuten
wird gleich der nächste Verfassungsbruch
sein weder 2023 noch 2024 besteht eine
Notsituation im Sinne des Artikel 115
Grundgesetz man halilt keinen
Verfassungsbruch durch einen weiteren
herrkanzler auch das demonstrative
entfernen an dieser Satz hilft ändert
daran überhaupt nichts
sie haben und Sie hören es ja noch als
Kanzler in einer ihrer ersten
Amtshandlungen zusammen mit dem neuen
Finanzminister Lindner den absurden
nachtragshausalt 21 dann im Januar 22
beschlossen und darin auch schon die
eindeutig verfassungswidrige
buchungssystematik die illegalen Kredite
der Sondervermögen über viele Milliarden
Euro sollten die Spardose sein zur
Umsetzung der gesellschaftsändernden rot
grün gelben Ziele
die gesamte Politik die allgemeinpolitik
der CO2 hysterischen energievorgaben der
Masseneinwanderung der wen
gesellschaftstransformation der
industriefeindlichkeit der Milliarden
teuren Corona lockdowns und der
waffengeschenke ins Ausland wären ohne
diese Gelder nicht denkbar
gewesen leider leider hat ihn das
Verfassungsgericht ist jetzt die
finanzielle Geschäftsgrundlage entzogen
dutzende Milliarden zu spät
Deutschland wird nun schon seit vier
Jahren seit vier Jahren finanziell
notregiert es wht ein Hauch von Weimar
dort wurde ab 1930 notregiert meist
gestützt auf Notverordnungen seit 2020
werden von der groco und auch von der
Ampel durchgängig nun Notsituationen
erklärt die Schuldenbremse wird so
geschretdert das Grundgesetz anhaltend
umgangen und das müssen die Menschen
wissen die Grünen Chefin Ricarda lang
fordert sogar schon die dauerhafte
Aussetzung der verfassungsrechtlichen
Schuldenbremse Herr mützenig hat eben
auch mehr als angedeutet man fordert
einen permanenten Notstand wir werden
auch für die nächsten Jahre die
Aussetzung diskutieren müssen das ist
die Debatte die ansteht sagt Frau lang
die Ampel steht vor dem politischen
moralischen und finanziellen Bankrott
verfassungskonform kann das Land nur
noch mit einem grundlegenden Kurswechsel
regiert werden die selbsternannte
demokratische Mitte die acho
demokratische Mitte hat mit mindestens
drei Haushalten an der Verfassung
vorbeiegiert und der SPD Fraktionschef
hat ja eben an dieser Stelle vor wenigen
Minuten das Grundgesetz als Monstranz
bezeichnet als peinliche als peinliches
Relikt schämen sie sich Herr Mütz nicht
wo ist der Verfassungsschutz wenn man
ihn bräuchte wo ist er das sind
Anschläge gegen die FDGO hier an diesem
Pult man kann sich nicht dauerhaft aus
einer Krise drucken man kann kan die
Jahrzehnte alten Lebenslügen der Politik
alle Altparteien nicht dauerhaft mit
Schulden und Steuergeld kompensieren ich
habe das hier an dieser Stelle im
Bundestag schon bei der Ausrufung der
ersten Notsituation im März 2020 genauso
gesagt es geht immer noch nicht Herr
Scholz ihre von Anfang an ungedeckten
vorsätzlich illegal ausgestellten
Schecks haben die deutsche miserie sogar
verschlimmert wäre dieses Geld nicht
ausgegeben worden dann Sünde Deutschland
heute nicht nur finanziell S dann
umfassend besser da weil dann auch eine
Menge gesellschaftspolitischer Blödsinn
nicht finanzierbar gewesen
wäre und sie alle haben seit kolschen
scheckbuchzeiten mitgemacht die AFD ist
bereit diesen Schut wegzuräumen aber
erst dann wenn sie die
fäheentscheidungen einräumen und den Weg
für einen Neuanfang frei Maen für eine
endlich wieder rational national
geführte Regierung dann besteht trotz
der horrentenschäden durch seit 8 Jahren
aufgegebene Grenzen und durch Billionen
an zinstragender Verschuldung die noch
Haushalte bis0 belasten werden die
Chance auf Rettung Deutschlands mein
letzter Satz doch zunächst braucht es
ihren Abgang als läuternde katarsis der
in der klassischen Tragödie die
Voraussetzung für Heilung ist vielen
Dank
das für die AFD der haushaltspolitische
Sprecher meiner Seite einen schönen
guten Tag und ein herzliches Danke schön
für den für die netten Glückwünsche
heute Morgen und wir führen
in hat jetzt das Präsidium übernommen
frauel hat schon gratuliert wird heute
44 Jahre jung herzlichen Glückwunsch
auch von dieser Stelle Christop
meaktionvorspteil
buverfass weisenden Charakter wir spüren
das erleben wir seit dem 15 November die
Auswirkung kurzfristig und wir werden
längerfristig damit arbeiten müssen wir
werden in dieser Woche den
Nachtragshaushalt 2023 beschließen oder
einbringen um Rechtssicherheit
herzustellen es wird ein technischer
Nachtrag sein ohne zusätzliche Schulden
mein Kollege D hat bereits darauf
hingewiesen wir werden sogar mit 27
Milliarden Euro die Nettokreditaufnahme
deutlich reduzieren können und ich
möchte das an dieser Stelle auch wenn
wir am Freitag darüber diskutieren
werden noch mal klar sagen die 115er
Notlage bezieht sich auf die Situation
Anfang des Jahres
2023 und wenn wir gewusst hätten wie das
Bundesverfassungsgericht
urteilt und die Schuldenbremse auslegt
den hätten wir die Notlage für 2023
Anfang des Jahres
gezogen derndes
hat zurecht darauf hingewiesen dass der
Haushalt
2024 nach dem Prinzip Gründlichkeit vor
Schnelligkeit zu beraten ist und der hat
von einer neuen Realität gesprochen die
neue Realität ist die Härtung der
Schuldenbremse die Schuldenbremse steht
und ich andere Redner haben ja auch ihre
Perspektive hier geschildert ich sehe
keine Notlage in
2024 die am Ende die Kriterien des
Grundgesetzes erfüllen und a
leggungsmaßstab an den sich alle halten
müssen Konsolidierungsdruck rechtfertigt
kein Aussetzen der
Schuldenbremse wir dürfen nach dem
Verfassungsgerichtsurteil nicht in ein
weiterof ver
fallen und wir dürfen auch nicht auch
vor Respekt vor aufgrund des Respekts
vor dem Verfassungsgericht sofort in
einer Diskussion um die Reform der
Schuldenbremse verfallen auch da müssen
wir uns doch ehrlich machen auch da
müssen wir uns doch ehrlich machen wir
haben das ganze letzte Jahr
und dieses Jahr verschiedene Vorschläge
bekommen warum man gegebenenfalls eine
Notlage zusätzlich erklären könne und
wir haben in Wahrheit auch die Debatte
seit 2022 darüber dass man die
Schuldenbremse gegebenenfalls
reformieren möge oder solle mit der FDP
sehe ich hier wenig Gemeinsamkeiten wir
werden dies nicht zulassen in dieser
Regierung wir haben kein
einnme sagen wir müssen priorisieren und
wir müssen konsolidieren und das wäre
auf diese Koalition in Wahrheit auch bei
den Haushaltsberatung 2025 zugekommen
wir werden es jetzt machen müssen dies
wird härter werden wir müssen Ausgaben
beschränken der Kanzler hat das gesagt
und Schwerpunkte setzen
und ich möchte hier ebenfalls noch mal
auf die Situation in den Bundesländern
zu sprechen kommen das eine ist ja die
Frage wie unionsgeführte Länder oder
oder Länder wo die Union beteiligt ist
sich zu der Schuldenbremse und diesem
urteilverhalten und wie die
buchungspraxis in diesen Ländern
war und es ist glaube ich auch nicht
erstaunlich dass die Wirtschaftsminister
Anfang dieser Woche begrüßen und
bestätigen dass der Bund weiter mehr
Geld geben soll das ist ja das Prinzip
was die Bundesländer in den letzten
Jahrzehnten perfektioniert haben wenn
wir hier darüber reden dass 55
Milliarden Euro der Bund jetzt schon
übernimmt für die Länder D ist das z.B
auch ein Thema was wir uns per
angucken aber ich möchte hier die CDU
beim Wort nehmen Herr März sprach am
Anfang von nicht bekannter
Dreistigkeit ich frage sie was machen
sie in den Ländern wo neue
Sondervermögen eingerichtet werden die
eklatant gegen das Urteil aus karlsruh
verstoßen z.B hier in Berlin was machen
sie da Herr märz nicht mehr da ist aber
Herr andere reden ja noch von der CDU
können sich ja dazu mal Verhalten
Sprachen hier von einer
staatsbürgerlichen
Verantwortung die Verfassung einhalten
zu müssen oder dafür zu sorgen dass die
Verfassung einhält heißt das dass sie
eine konkrete normkontrolle gegen das
Land Berlin anstrengen werden als Union
das wäre konsequent wenn man ihnen
glauben könnte dass sie hier Verteidiger
der schenbremse sind ich komme zum
Schluss die Antwort können Sie
vielleicht geben vor uns liegen Wochen
der Wahrheit das ist gut so am Ende des
Tages werden wir das Land stärker
aufstellen wenn wir den Haushalt 24
aufgestellt haben ich danke
ihnen Christop Meer hat hier die
Wahrheit am Schluss ausgesprochen wenn
dieser Haushalt 2024 aufgestellt wird
darüber werden die fraktionäre noch ein
wenig streiten wie das geschehen soll
nächster Redner Achim Post erste
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
für die SPD sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen meine Damen und
Herren wenn man diese Debatte verfolgt
hat und und das haben wir alle gemacht
die einen mehr die anderen weniger ich
mehr komme ich zu dem Schluss dass ich
mir gewünscht hätte dass es nach dem
Urteil von Karlsruhe das genauso ist wie
die
Fraktionsvorsitzenden der Grünen der SPD
und der FDP beschrieben haben ein Urteil
das wir sehr ernst nehmen als Ampel und
als koalitionsfraktion ich hätte mir
gewünscht etwas gerade auf Seiten der
Unionsfraktion etwas weniger
Schadenfreude
etwas weniger
Häme etwas weniger Triumphgefühl oder
Gefühle und dafür etwas mehr am besten
sogar deutlich mehr Bereitschaft zur
Verantwortung zur wirklichen
Zusammenarbeit denn das ist das was wir
angesichts der Lage in der wir nun
wirklich sind die man sich nicht
ausdenkt ja nun wirklich sind bei
Kriegen in der Ukraine bei einem enkrieg
in der Ukraine wo kein Ende abzusehen
ist bei einer Lage im Nahen Osten die
nach dem menschenverachtenden Angriff
von Hamas auf Israel außerkontrolle
geraten könnte nicht muss und in einer
Lage liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wo
es darum geht wo wir in globaler
Konkurrenz bei einer sich zuspitzenden
Klimakrise unsere Wirtschaft umbauen
wollen ökologisch umbauen wollen dann
ist es ja wohl dringend Nöten auch mal
darüber zu reden wie man genug Geld für
Investition für Zukunftsinvestition
mobilisieren
kann und mein Fraktionsvorsitzender rolf
mützenig hat darauf hingewiesen dass es
um mehr geht als das was der eine oder
andere hier gerade angesprochen hat es
geht auch um die Frage ob in Zeiten wie
diesen der soziale Zusammenhalt in
diesem Land der enorm unter Druck
geraten ist dadurch besser würde in ind
dem man an eine sozialstad rangeht und
kürzen will bei Krankenhäusern Pflege
und Gesundheit liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen müssen sie gleich sagen müssen
sie gleich sagen zum WSF und zum
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfond und zum
Klima und transformationsfond das sind
ja keine Dinge die man sich aus Lust und
Tollerei ausgedacht hat sondern wir
haben ja wohl die Notwendigkeit für die
Transformation unserer Wirtschaft und
wir haben ja wohl die Notwendigkeit was
für Klimaschutz zu tun und es ist gut
es ist sogar sehr gut dass wir den
Wirtschafts und stabilisierungsfond
geschaffen haben und mit Finanzmitteln
ausgestattet haben denn damit haben wir
energiepreisbremsen organisiert die
Millionen von Menschen geholfen haben
die unseren Betrieben geholfen haben um
sicher sicherer durch diese Krise zu
kommen und das ist durch diese Politik
des Bundeskanzlers und der Ampel
gelungen Liebe Kolleginen und
Kollegen und wenn wir über
den Haushalt 23 reden ist es ja wohl das
Mindeste was man erwarten kann dass am
besten alle demokratischen Fraktion in
diesem Hause zustimmen denn wir reden
darüber dass wir ansonsten wenn wir
diesen Haushalt jetzt so nicht machen
würden die Bürgerinnen und Bürger ja
wohl bitten müssten das was sie bekommen
haben an energiepreisbremsen
zurückzuzahlen und wir müssen die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in
nordin-westfalen und in rheinlandpalz im
ahal in badmünster Eifel in Hagen darum
bitten doch die Hilfen die angefangen
haben zurückzuholen und die müssen wir
weiter bezahlen und die wollen wir
weiter bezahlen deshalb liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen es war richtig
den WSF zu schaffen und es ist richtig
dass wir das so machen wie diese
Bundesregierung es jetzt
vorschlägt und
dann kommen wir noch mal zu dem was an
Kritik geäußert
wurde was ich rausgehört habe was an
Kritik geäußert wurde in der
Bereinigungssitzung war das nicht
möglich weil die Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der CDU CSU zwar körperlich
anwesend waren aber sich an der Debatte
nicht beteiligt haben sie haben 14
Stunden geschwiegen 14 Stunden keine
eigenen Vorschläge gemacht und ich hatte
mir erhofft dass diese Vorschläge heute
kommen vielleicht kommen sie ja jetzt
wenn man Kritik übt sollte man das
reflektiert machen in der Zeit nicht nur
der großen Koalition in der
Regierungszeit von Angela Merkel hat es
14 Sondervermögen gegeben
14 angefangen von der uung über die
digitale Infrastruktur hin zu der
fluthilfe alles sinnvolle Maßnahmen
sagen Sie das doch mal dass das
vernünftig war liebe Kollegin und
Kollegen von der CDU CSU machen sie das
noch
mal und wenn wir über den Haushalt 24
reden natürlich müssen wir darüber reden
wie wir das was wir uns vorgenommen
haben wie das was dringend geboten ist
finanziert wird und ich verstehe
überhaupt nicht wo man von vorne rein
meint man müsse eines der möglichen
Instrumente vom Tisch nehmen natürlich
muss man darüber nachdenken ob es
sinnvoll ist die Schuldenbremse auch in
24 auszusetzen denn sonst denn sonst
müssen wir darüber nachdenken dazu
kürzen bei Dingen die ich gerade
angesprochen habe dann sagen Sie uns das
doch wo sie das wollen wollen sie kürzen
beim Sozialstaat wollen sie kürzen bei
der Rente wollen sie kürzen bei der
Pflege machen Sie noch mal Vorschläge
ich habe von ihnen in den letzten 10
Tagen seit dem Urteil in Karlsruhe
nichts aber auch rein gar nichts
gehört und wenn wir schon mal dabei sind
ganz zum Schluss dieser Debatte wo sich
die Demokraten darüber streiten was der
richtige Weg ist kann ich nach dem
unflätigen Verhalten ist noch das
netteste Wort was mir einfällt gerade zu
Beginn dieser Debatte von Seiten ganz
rechts außen nur eins sagen es ist
richtig und bleibt richtig sie sind
keine Alternative für Deutschland sie
sind eine Schande für die
bundesholik und deshalb zusammengefasst
diese Ampel und unter der Führung des
Bundeskanzlers unter der Führung des
Finanzministers undter der Führung des
Wirtschaftsministers haben ordentliche
Vorschläge gemacht meine Fraktion wir
das unterstützen schönen
Dank der Bundeskanzler hat heute morgen
seine Regierungserklärung abgehalten und
der Bundestag debattiert nach wie vor
darüber nächster Redner hier Matthias
Middelberg für die CD frau Präsidentin
liebe Kolleginnen liebe Kollegen ich
muss mich leider dem Urteil anschließen
dass die Rede des Bundeskanzlers heute
maximal enttäuschend war und zwar nicht
nur mit dem Blick nach hinten was die
Verursachung dieser Misere
angeht Stichwort keinerlei Demut aber
vor allen Dingen auch keinerlei
Eingeständnis der
Mogelei um die Schuldenbremse herum an
der sie ja selbst Herr Bundeskanzler
atpersam maßgeblich beteiligt waren aber
noch schlimmer will ich Ihnen gleich
erklären Herr Meer noch schlimmer ist
dass der Blick in die Zukunft wie wir
die Lage jetzt bereinigen ja noch
trostloser ist weil sie nichts konkretes
sagen konnten zum Haushalt für das
nächste Jahr zum Haushalt
2024 und wir haben hier jetzt in der
Debatte völlig unterschiedliche
Standpunkte dazu gehört die einen wollen
noch mal die notlagenklausel bedienen
die anderen wollen den Haushalt jetzt
noch mal grundlegend umstellen also die
Bürger und das ist das entscheidende
dieses Land befindet sich in einer
ernsthaften Lage die Bürger sind maximal
verunsichert aber den entscheidenden
Beitrag dazu liefern sie selbst ihre
eigene Regierung dieser permanente
ampelstreit sie sind und das hat der
Kollege bscher genau richtig
angesprochen jetzt kann man ja mit so
einem Urteil und einem anderen Urteil
rechnen aber sie haben sich ja noch
nicht mal auf den Fall dieses Urteils
vorbereitet von dem Plan B von dem
irgendwie die Rede war haben wir nichts
bisher erlebt Null sie haben keinen Plan
B für das nächste Jahr hat diese
Regierung kein haushalterisches Konzept
das ist die Bilanz dieser Debatte und
das ist ein katastrophenzeugnis für Sie
Herr Bundeskanzler um es ganz klar zu
sagen Herr müzen nicht ich sag ihnen sie
haben eben das Verfassungsgericht
kritisiert das hätte ja mal ein bisschen
zeitiger und dies und das sein sie mal
froh se froh dass das Verfassungsgericht
noch in diesem Jahr entschieden hat
jetzt haben sie noch die Chance ein
Nachtragshaushalt zu machen und die Lage
zu reparieren hätte das
Verfassungsgericht im Januar entschieden
dann hätten sie die komplette Lücke von
45 Milliarden im Nachhinein auffüllen
müssen das wäre der komplette Bankrott
für ihre Politik gewesen lieber Herr
Kollege Melber glauben Sie eine
Zwischenfrage vom Kollegen autrit
gerne
sehrter Herr
Mittelberg der Regierende Bürgermeister
von Berlin Kai Wegner fordert eine
Reform der Schuldenbremse und hat hier
gerade einen Maulkorb durch den
parteichf Friedrich März erteilt
bekommen die ostministerpräsidenten
wollen ebenfalls eine Reform der
Schuldenbremse in
Schleswig-Holstein wird die Notlage auch
2024 noch mal ausgeruf
und in SachsenAnhalt haben wir eben auch
erfahren auch dort wird
2023224 die Notlage ausgerufen auch ein
CDU Ministerpräsident Herr haselhof wie
erklären sie eigentlich dieses Chaos in
der CDU und wir erklären Sie dass Sie
keinerlei Vorschlag hier bringen können
tatsächlich mal systematisch diese
Fragen zu
lösen lieber Kollege a vielen Dank für
Ihre Zwischenfrage ich kann kein Chaos
in der CDU zu diesem Punkt
erkennen es geht da jeweils es geht da
jeweils um die entsprechenden Klauseln
in den länderverfassungen und die sind
auch höchst unterschiedlich ausgestaltet
wir reden hier über die Schuldenbremse
im Grundgesetz für ja in der Folge da
haben sie recht Herr Fricker aber wir
haben für den Bund und wir reden ja hier
heute über ihren Haushalt und ihre
Haushaltspolitik darüber reden wir sie
haben z.B ich will es ihnen gerne
erklären im kommenden Jahr ein schuldung
Spielraum innerhalb der Schuldenbremse
von allein ca 22 Milliarden sie hatten
auch für dieses Jahr ein großen
Spielraum und den haben sie komplett
ausgeschöpft also sie haben auch
innerhalb einer Schuldenbremse durchaus
Flexibilität aber ich will ihn gerne
generelle Bemerkung auch als Antwort mit
auf den Weg geben das Schuldenmachen der
Vergangenheit führt jetzt dazu dass wir
in unserem
Bundeshaushalt 40 Milliarden jedes Jahr
aufwenden nur für Zinszahlung hätten wir
in der Vergangenheit nicht so viele
Schulden gemacht und dann nehme ich uns
auch selber in die Verantwortung hätten
wir nicht so viele Schulden gemacht dann
hätten wir mit der jetzigen Lage
überhaupt gar kein Problem weil wir
jedes Jahr 40 Milliarden mehr zur
Verfügung hätten um die Probleme zu
lösen und die 60 Milliarden die ihnen
fehlen aus dem Nachtragshaushalt die
ziehen sich ja über mehrere Jahre das
heißt diese Lücken könnten sie locker
auffüllen so und ich will ihn noch einen
weiteren Punkt
nennen sie haben hier noch mal Herr D
wieder strapaziert es beträfe auch
vorgängerreierung diese buchungspraxis
ich habe ihnen mal mitgebracht die Seite
160 aus ihrem eigenen Koalitionsvertrag
und den können Sie mal nachlesen da
haben sie diese buchungsregel nämlich
bewusst geändert im letzten Satz steht
da zu lesen entsprechend wird die
Befüllung eines Sondervermögens als
Abfluss aus dem Kernhaushalt den
verschuldenspielraum reduzieren sie
haben ersetzt die Regel dass der das
gezählt wird zu dem Zeitpunkt wenn der
Bund einen Kredit begibt haben sie
geändert ganz bewusst durch eine interne
Umbuchung vom Kernhaushalt in das
Sondervermögen das hat ihnen diesen
faulen WSF ermöglicht und wenn Sie diese
Regelung in ihrem eigenen
Koalitionsvertrag Herr D hören Sie mal
sorgfältig zu nicht beschlossen hätten
dann hätten sie jetzt keinen
verfassungswidrigen WSF das heißt wir
müssten gar keinen Nachtragshaushalt für
dieses Jahr machen wir bräuchten keinen
Nachtragshaushalt das ist der Punkt und
spannend und das möchte ich Ihnen
abschließend mit auf den Weg geben
spannend wird noch zu klären sein wer
die eigentlich ursächlichen
Verantwortlichen für diese Umgehung der
Schuldenbremse waren denn mit der
Entlassung von Herrn Gatzer da haben sie
völlig Recht der mützenig ist es nicht
getan aber die Blicke wenen sich dann
nicht an auf Herr L der wenigstens mal
so mutig war die politische
Verantwortung zu übernehmen sondern die
wenden sich an den Herrn Bundeskanzler
denn der ist der Auftraggeber
dieser Herz
dan Matthias midelberg von der Union hat
hier noch mal dargestellt dass es
durchaus Unterschiede gibt beim
Schuldenmachen nächster Redner jetzt
Sebastian Schäfer für
Dieb
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin Herr
Bundeskanzler sehr geehrte Kolleginnen
und Kollegen es ist das
Selbstverständliche Recht der Opposition
vor das Bundesverfassungsgericht zu
ziehen das ist essentiell in unserem
Rechtsstaat die Union hat mit ihrer
Klage Recht bekommen und wir müssen
konstatieren dass dieses Urteil
tiefgreifende Auswirkungen auf die
finanziellen Gestaltungsmöglichkeiten
von Bund und Ländern hat wer
Verantwortung trägt und das tun wir auf
den verschiedenen Ebenen in der
Demokratischen Mitte dieses Hauses der
muss in schwierigen Zeiten Lösungen
finden z.B endlich umweltschädliche
Subventionen abbauen da steht ja auch in
unserem Koalitionsvertrag und da gibt's
Potenzial die ökonomische Situation in
unserem Land war schon vor dem Urteil
schwierig unsere Wirtschaft stagniert
ein drastischer Einbruch konnte in in
diesem Jahr verhindert werden unsere
Bürgerinnen und Bürger unsere
Unternehmen haben sehr rational agiert
gerade im vergangenen Winter wir haben
das als Koalition mit den richtigen
Mitteln unterstützt mit preisbremsen mit
Unterstützung für die Industrie das war
finanzverfassungsrechtlich falsch
aufgesetzt deshalb korrigieren wir das
jetzt aber kommen wir mal zum soliden
Haushalten der Union wir haben bei der
einzelplanberatung keine Anträge der
Union gesehen Teil lag zwar vorher dem
Spiegel vor die wurden dann aber
kurzfristig wieder zurückgezogen deshalb
beziehe ich mich auf einen plenarantrag
den sie hier vor wenigen Wochen
eingebracht haben sie wollen den
Verteidigungshaushalt um 10 Milliarden
Euro erhöhen darüber kann man reden aber
da muss man auch über eine
Gegenfinanzierung reden was haben sie da
vorgelegt zu Lasten des Gesamthaushalts
also 10 Milliarden die da irgendwie im
Bundeshaushalt rumschwirren sie wissen
nicht wo weil Sie genau wissen dass das
nicht so einfach ist deshalb legen sie
endlich Konzepte
vor gerade jetzt werden infolge der
Pandemie und der geostrategischen
Verschiebungen auf der Welt viele
Produktionsketten neu aufgest gestellt
auch deshalb ist diese Zeit jetzt so
entscheidend für unsere Volkswirtschaft
unsere wirtschaftliche Verbindung zu
China ist stark damit entsteht ein
weiteres Risiko wir sehen doch wie sich
China im globalen Wettbewerb aufstellt
da geht es sehr gezielt um die Märkte
auf denen die Unternehmen aus
Deutschland in den vergangenen
Jahrzehnten so erfolgreich waren es geht
da um den Kern unseres Wohlstandes nicht
nur bei uns in Baden-Württemberg im
ganzen
Land unsere Unternehmen unsere Industrie
die wirtschaftsministerinnen und
Minister aus Bund und Ländern aber auch
die ökonominen und Ökonomen in unserem
Land sind sich einig wir müssen gerade
jetzt die Zukunftsfähigkeit unserer
Volkswirtschaft unterstützen sonst
brechen uns Kompetenzen weg sonst drohen
fadenrisse es liegen die ersten
makroökonomischen Studien vor die die
Folgen eines möglichen Ausfalls
staatlicher Unterstützung für die
Transformation aufzeigen wir können es
uns doch nicht leisten dass unser
Wachstum im nächsten Jahr um fast 1%
sinkt wie das projizziert wird das
betrifft 10tausende neue Arbeitsplätze
die nicht geschaffen werden das hat
negative Konsequenzen auch für die
Lohnsteigerungen das Hemd private
Investitionstätigkeit und die
unternehmerischen Aktivitäten im Land
das behindert Innovation all das was wir
jetzt so dringend brauchen wir dürfen im
globalen Wettbewerb nicht weiter an
Boden verlieren rolf mützenig hat das
ausgeführt wir werden die
Herausforderungen der Demografie der
Digitalisierung der Energiewende der
geopolitischen Herausforderungen nicht
ohne einen grundlegenden Umbau der
Infrastruktur eine Modernisierung des
Kapitalstocks schaffen es geht jetzt um
die Zukunftsfähigkeit unseres Landes das
ist unsere gemeinsame Verantwortung
herzlichen
Dank und der nächste Redner meine Damen
und Herren ist einer der fraktionslosen
abgeordnet Verena Hubert oh nein da war
ich verrutscht zunächst kommt Verena
Hubert von der SPD sie ist
stellvertreten Fraktionsvorsitzende der
Sozialdemokraten
nicht aber ich bin auch
da sie stehen auf meiner Liste als
nächste Rednerin und als übernächste
Redner kommt erst
her gut dass es auch noch mal den ein
oder anderen Zettel gibt für die SPD
Fraktion hat jetzt das
Wort sehrehrte frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen müssen uns doch
in dieser Debatte mal bewusst machen wo
wir eigentlich gerade stehen nämlich an
einem Scheidepunkt es geht darum wie wir
unser Land gut aufstellen für die
Zukunft und wie wir die Transformation
auch schaffen und dabei und das muss man
sich mal klar machen kann man auch nicht
nur gewinnen sondern es gibt auch jede
Menge zu verlieren und deswegen ist das
was wir hier Vorhaben auch keine Kü
sondern eine Pflicht und Verantwortung
die wir alle miteinander tragen hier
auch gute Lösungen zu finden finden und
natürlich ist diese Transformation auch
eine
Jahrhundertaufgabe und nicht etwas dass
wir einfach mal so tun sondern wir
müssen doch dafür sorgen dass
zukünftiges Wirtschaftswachstum hier
auch möglich ist Arbeitsplätze entstehen
Arbeitsplätze auch gehalten werden
können unser Fraktionsvorsitzender rolf
mützenig hat eben noch mal klar gemacht
wir müssen nicht nur über den Atlantik
gucken was die USA machen mit dem
Inflation reduction Act da reicht auch
der Blick nach Großbritannien wo
Milliarden mobilisiert werden um
Zukunftsindustrien anzusiedeln und das
wollen und das müssen wir auch im Sinne
einer aktiven Wirtschaftspolitik hier in
Deutschland tun Batterien Halbleiter
Wasserstoff das ist doch der Motor der
dieses Land hier zukünftig auch am
Laufen hält und deswegen darf er nicht
in Stottern
kommen und Liebe Union liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen von der CDU CSU wir haben
wahrgenommen sie wünschen sich die 90er
Jahre zurück das heißt aber auch ganz
konkret
Massenarbeitslosigkeit Jahre der
Rekordverschuldung und nicht zuletzt
einen kompletten Reformstau bei dem wir
teilweise heute noch beschäftigt sind
das ganze mal wieder zu beheben
Stichwort kasfaser und deswegen muss man
Herrn März ja fast danken dass er heute
mal kurz die Maske abgesetzt hat und
seine ja doch etwas rückwärtsgeandte
Weltsicht hier präsentiert hat früher
war alles besser und am liebsten noch
mal zurück dahin danke
schön wir haben andere Ideen für die
Zukunft unseres Landes und wir wollen
uns jetzt auch alle ernsthaft
miteinander die Frage stellen wie
kriegen wir das gemeinsam hin und die
Situation ist ernst die Situation
erfordert unser aller Verantwortung mir
macht Mut wenn ich die Ampel sehe dass
wir immer gut und gerne miteinander
diskutieren das wir auch natürlich an
anderen Blick haben auf die Dinge aber
dass wir es am Ende des Tages auch
miteinander hinbekommen die großen
Fragen unserer Zeit auch zu lösen und
das werden wir auch diesmal wieder
miteinander
schaffen und natürlich akzeptieren wir
das Gerichtsurteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts und natürlich
müssen jetzt alle Vorschläge auf den
Tisch wie wir diese großen benötigten
Milliarden Investitionen auch stemmen es
ist aber auch unsere Aufgabe als Politik
nicht immer nur Schubladen aufzumachen
und Konzepte rauszupacken die wir alle
schon kennen sondern man darf ja auch
mal über den Tellerrand hinausschauen
wir als SPD Bundestagsfraktion haben in
Dresden letztes Jahr Papiere beschlossen
macht man gerne macht man oft aber ich
finde da gibt's auch noch einen
Vorschlag drin der uns ganz konkret
vielleicht ein Teil dieser Antwort auch
mitliefern kann und zwar haben wir wir
uns einen staatsfond ausgesprochen der
auch tatsächlich ein Fond ist wo wir
privates Kapital auch in diesem Land
mithebeln für die Innovationskraft
dieses Landes und die zukünftige
Infrastruktur die es doch jetzt genau zu
modernisieren gilt und da lade ich Sie
alle gerne ein auch mal Konzepte mit auf
den Tisch zu bringen und nicht nur Häme
nicht nur Freude über das wo wir hier
alle gerade miteinander Aufgaben unseres
Landes zu lösen
habente Kolleginnen und Kollegen lassen
sie mich zum Schluss kommen der
Bundeskanzler hat eben noch mal
dargelegt in welchen multiplen Krisen
und Kriegen wir uns befinden und da ist
die Welt nicht so wie wir sie uns in
aller Gemütlichkeit der 90er Jahre
vielleicht manchmal zurückwünschen und
deswegen sage ich Ärmel hochkrempeln
Kraftanstrengung Lösungen finden dafür
sind wir gewählt und das werden wir auch
miteinander
hinkriegen
war das für die SPD die stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende und jetzt einer der
vielen fraktionslosen Abgeordneten hier
ich habe es vorhin schon mal angekündigt
der auch sehr häufig sich zu Wort meldet
das ist Robert
fahle sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und
Herren das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat
ein klares Urteil gesprochen die
Umwidmung der cor
Kreditermächtigungen zur Umgehung der
Schuldenbremse war ein vorsätzlicher
Verfassungsbruch die Umsetzung des
gesamten Koalitionsvertrages der Ampel
beruht dementsprechend auf Täuschung und
betrug der jetzt aufgeflogen ist es
sollten Steuergelder in Milliardenhöhe
veruntreut werden und für die große
grüne Transformation verschwendet werden
die im Ergebnis darauf abzielt die
soziale Marktwirtschaft in in eine
ökosozialistische Planwirtschaft
umzubauen das Geschäftsmodell der Ampel
besteht im Kern darin unsere
Energiebasis und kernindustrien
mutwillig zu zerstören und die negativen
Folgen dieser
Fehlentscheidungen mit Schulden
finanzierten subventionsprogrammen zu
vertuschen um den großen Aufschrei in
der Bevölkerung zu vermeiden und den
Traum vom CO2 freien
wolkenkckucksheim weiter träumen zu
können heizungswänd Atom und
Kohleausstieg der Verzicht auf das
russische Erdgas die Sackgasse mit der
Wasserstoffwirtschaft die sich in
nächsten Jahren so erweisen wird weil
das geht nämlich gar nicht wie sie das
wollen das Märchen vom grünen stahlplatz
sowieso schon die Zerstörung der
Automobilindustrie durch das
verbrennerverbot sind allesamt keine
Investition in die Zukunft sondern
katastrophale Fehlentscheidung und
unsere Wirtschaft wird schneller vor die
Wand gefahren die zwelle rollt die große
grüne Transformation ist nichts weiter
als ein
deindustrialisierungs und
umverteilungsprogramm von unten nach
oben Konzerne kassieren die
fördergeldmilliarden von Herrn habbeck
während die Bürger auf den
Staatsschulden Jahrzehnt lang hängen
bleiben die sie über ihre Steuern
jahrzehntang abzahlen
müssen frage ich mich was bleibt jetzt
von dieser Debatte
übrig die Ampel trickst mit unserer
Verfassung nicht unsere Verfassung sie
ist das Bündnis von verfassungsfeinen
aus dem Bundestag das ist die Erkenntnis
die man aus dieser Debatte rausziehen
muss ihre Redezeit ist vorbei und ich
komme zum Schluss es hilft nur
eins strafsanktionen gibt es noch nicht
die fordere ich aber hiermit dass auch
Politiker für solches Handeln bestraft
werden können und in Haftung genommen
werden können in Zukunft und der letzte
Satz das ist der letzte wirklich meine
Damen und Herren der Wähler soll
entscheiden nur noch Leute ins Parlament
zu wählen die verantwortlich handeln und
ihre Wort
halten vielen Dank dass Sie diesen
Antrag hier eingebracht haben das
Verfassungsgericht gut vielen
Dank leider ist es Beier immer so dass
er seine Redezeit grundsätzlich etwas
überzieht das kennen wir hier im
Parlament
schonäidentin Herr F bei ihnen ist noch
nicht mal ein Shakespeare Zitat richtig
da kann ich nur no den Titel sagen wie
immer viel Lärm um nichts bei Ihnen
meine Damen und Herren ich habe am
Anfang die etwas schwierige Aufgabe
meinem Fraktionsvorsitzenden
widersprechen zu müssen er hat gesagt
Markus Söder hätte bisher noch nichts
zur Schuldenbremse gesagt sei ja erst
Dienstag ich muss ihn leider korrigieren
letztes Jahr hat Markus Söder der
Kollege dobrin weiß das hat das aber in
seiner zehminütigen Rede bewusst
verschwiegen ganz bewusst vor einem Jahr
gesagt er stelle die Schuldenbremse in
Frage er zweifle am Sinn der
Schuldenbremse wörtlich Hilfe für Land
und Leute geht vor Prinzipien Reiterei
und das ist das was diese Koalition mit
dem hausalt 23 macht weil ihnen Land und
Leute wichtiger ist als ihre juristische
Prinzipienreiterei meine Damen und
Herren und dann sagt ja die CDU CSU
leider ist der Fraktionsvorsitzende
jetzt schon weg sie hätte doch ganz
genau gewusst dass klar war dass hier
eine Verfassungswidrigkeit bezüglich der
60 Milliarden dass das nichtichtig ist
dass man das nicht hätte machen dürfen
und Papier ist ja geduldig es gibt eine
Drucksache 204579
Entschließungsantrag der CDU CSU
Fraktion unter der Führung Führung
geht's ja anscheinend rum von Friedrich
März da steht dann das Vorgehen beim
zweiten Nachtragshaushalt mit der
Umwidmung der coronakredite in
klimakredite und der Transfer in Höhe
von 60 Milliarden
ist Rück abzuwickeln und Achtung und
jetzt kommt der verräterische Satz und
damit die Neuverschuldung zu senken sie
wollten diese 60 Milliarden nicht
streichen sie wollten sie nutzen für
ihre Programme was sie danach in ihrem
Antrag gemacht haben und wer dann
dahingeht und sagt das ist ja alles
überhaupt nicht überraschend gewesen
obwohl er selber das für ntig erklärte
Geld genutzt hat der sollte hier in
diesem Plenum mal ganz andere Worte
verwenden meine Damen und Herren es geht
do im Kern es geht doch im Kern meine
Damen und Herren um etwas ganz anderes
hier es geht um die Frage dass wir alle
merken dass die Frage wie dieses Land in
den letzten Jahrzehnten bei ihnen in den
90ern bei ihnen in den 30ern die Linken
sind schon fast ganz weg dass dieses
Land vor Herausforderung steht und egal
wer an der Regierung ist wir werden uns
verändern müssen es gibt dieses
wunderbare Zitat von joseppe Tomasi die
Lampedusa wenn wir wollen dass alles so
bleibt wie es ist dann ist es nötig dass
sich alles ändert und das ist das was
wir klar machen müssen was diese
Koalition auch will weil sie weiß dass
wichtig ist dass etwas bleibt dass
dieses Land ausmacht ein
marktwirtschaftlicher ein sozialer ein
verantwortungsvoller ein nachhaltiger
Staat das ist das Ziel dieser Koalition
und ich habe immer noch die Hoffnung
dass das auch noch das Ziel der CDO CSU
in den nächsten zwei Jahren hier sein
wird und schließlich geht es dabei doch
um etwas ganz Wichtiges geht doch um das
Versprechen der Bürgerin Bürger wenn ihr
leistet wenn ihr euch bildet dann werdet
ihr einen Aufstieg haben dann werdet ihr
für die Zukunft arbeiten können dann
werden wir gemeinsam dieses Land
voranbringen dabei dann zu sagen dass
alles nur durch Obstruktion der
Opposition hinzukriegen ist mag ihre
Aufgabe sein aber am Ende wenn Wahlen
kommen werden die Bürgerin und Bürger
die Frage stellen wer hat
verfassungsrechlich verantwortlich
gehandelt wer hat doch kritisiert wo die
Kritik notwendig ist und wer hat da
unterstützt wo es notwendig ist um
dieses Land voranzubringen das wird die
Aufgabe sein und meine Damen und Herren
zum Schluss möchte ich zwei drei Dinge
aus dem Teil doch noch malen die Frage
der Buchungsregeln sind das eine aber
sie kommen gar nicht an die Prüfung der
Buchungsregeln wenn sie sich das Urteil
genauer angucken Herr Middelberg sie
kommen da gar nicht ran wenn sie vorher
schon sagen dass die jährigkeit und
Jährlichkeit das ist worum es geht und
das haben sie scheinbar bisher noch
nicht erkannt und sollten mal darüber
nachdenken was das eigentlich in Zukunft
bedeutet für die Menschen an der A wenn
das Verfassungsgericht sagt das geht
nicht wie werden wir es gemeinsam
schaffen dass wir sagen wir stehen für
euch da wir werden euch helfen egal wie
lange er braucht um die Krisen
hinzukommen egal wie lange ihr braucht
um euer Haus wieder hinzubekommen und
ähnliches mehr nach ihrer Meinung geht
das alles ja gar nicht mehr nach unserer
Meinung und so auch entsprechend dann im
Nachtragshaushalt werden wir helfen
meine Damen und Herren eines werden die
nächsten Wochen zeigen wer Verantwortung
zeigt und wer einfach nur
oppositionspielchen macht herzlichen
Dank der haushaltspolitische sprech
Sprecher der FDP war das und die
letzteedin de die
stellvertretende Vorsitzende des
Haushaltsausschusses nämlich Bettina
haged von der spdidentin liebe Kollegin
liebe Kollegen lieber Otto Fricke es ist
sehr schön dass ich direkt an deine Rede
anknüpfen kann denn du hast sehr
plausibel gemacht für unsere zuhörerinen
und Zuhörer dass die Besserwisserei von
der hier der Oppositionsführer Friedrich
marz gesprochen hat damit hat er zwar
gemeint die Regierungsbank zu me
Wahrheit ist es aber so dass die besser
Wisser dort sitzen und die fehlende
Demut Kollege Dobrind die Sie
angesprochen haben hier in ihrer
besserwisserischen Rede das ist schon
sehr befremdlich dass sie die nicht an
Tag legen wenn sie doch der Erfinder der
pkwmaut sind wenn sie doch derjenige
waren der EU der eurecht hier missachtet
hat und der den Nachfolger andreas
Scheuer in die Situation gebracht hat
einen dreistelligen Millionen Betrag zu
lassen des
Steuerzahlers hier wirklich zu
veruntreuen so muss man es ja nennen und
leider ist es ja so dass sie auch kein
einzigen Vorschlag dazu gemacht haben
wie sie eigentlich den Menschen im
arteil hier die Hand reichen wollen und
weil das so bedauerlich ist wie sie ihre
Rolle hier als große Oppositionspartei
wahrnehmen will ich Ihnen mal ein
Spiegel vorhalten wie das in meinem
Heimatland schlesig-holstein läuft in
meinem Heimatland schlesigholstein davon
war schon
gibt es eine schwarzgrüne Regierung mit
einem CDU Ministerpräsidenten Daniel
Günther und die werden die
Haushaltsnotlage für
2023 und
2024 das möge man sich auf der Zunge
zergehen lassen erklären und wie verhält
sich dann eigentlich der
Oppositionsführer in
Schleswig-Holstein der ist nämlich
Sozialdemokrat und heißt Thomas LSE
Müller und da hat letzte Woche eine Rede
im Landtag gehalten wo er als
Oppositionsführer an die anderen
Kolleginen und Kollegen in der in der
Opposition appelliert hat in dieser
Situation die Landesregierung nicht im
Regen stehen zu lassen und er hat unter
anderem gesagt in seiner Rede mit keinem
Wort hat das Verfassungsgericht
ausgeschlossen dass wir
Klimaschutzmaßnahmen über Notkredite
finanzieren ich begrüße deshalb den von
CD und grün angekündigten Weg auch für
das Jahr 2023 20 24 eine erneute
Haushaltsnotlage festzustellen um die
jetzt notwendigen Mittel rechtssicher zu
mobilisieren und um ehrlich zu sein wäre
das auch der Weg den die Ampel in Berlin
gehen sollte alle wissen dass es die
Mittel aus dem KTF braucht für die
Wirtschaft das Verfassungsgericht hat
den Weg dahin beschrieben die
schlesäwilich-holsteinische CDU macht
vor wie das geht das ist doch mal ein
guter und konstruktiver Beitrag aus
ihren rein und es ist vor allen Dingen
eine großartige Leistung dass der
Oppositionsführer da unser Kollege von
der SPD sich eben ganz anders verhält
als Sie das hier tun ich möchte mit
Blick darauf dass wir ja noch diese
Woche den
2023er Haushalt heilen werden und die
Regierung hat ja dazu einen Vorschlag
gemacht mit dem Nachtragshaushalt den
wir am Freitag diskutieren und dann noch
im
Haushaltsausschuss und die
Sachverständigen Anhörung die der
Haushaltsausschuss in der letzten
Sitzungswoche gehabt hat hat ja ganz
klar den Weg beschrieben wie wir zu
verfassungskonform Haushalten 20 23 20
24 kommen und viele haben her schon
gesagt das Parlament das ist die
Sternstunde das ist unser Haushalts und
Budgetrecht und das ist richtig und
darum will ich auch an einen anderen
Christdemokraten hier erinnern der
frühere Bundestagspräsident Norbert
Lammert der hat hier in diesem Plenum
nämlich sinngemäß mehrfach geäußert in
einer Demokratie ist es nicht eine
Regierung die sich ein Parlament hält
sondern es ist ein Parlament das vom
Volk direkt gewählt ist dass eine
Regierung wählt und sie kontrolliert und
übrigens wählen wir auch unsere
Verfassungsrichter und weil das so ist
und jetzt die Stunde des Parlaments ist
möchte ich als stellvertretende
Haushaltsausschuss Vorsitzende ein
Wunsch äußern ein Wunsch auch an unsere
Regierung wir werden 23er Haushalt sehr
zeitnah jetzt auf einen
verfassungskonform Weg bringen aber wir
alle diskutieren im Haushaltsausschuss
seit September den 24er Haushalt und wir
brauchen dringend Planungssicherheit in
diesem Land wir müssen den Menschen den
Wohlfahrtsverbänden der Wirtschaft wir
müssen allen wieder zeigen wir sind in
der Lage diese unsich Situation wieder
zu ordnen und übrigens wir sind es auch
international in der Verantwortung denn
viele Partnerinnen und Partner sind auch
letztenendes davon abhängig dass wir sie
auch finanziell unterstützen und weil
das so ist darum erwarte ich dass wir
unsere Bereinigungssitzung die wir am
16 15inhalb Stunden geführt haben und
die Beschlüsse die wir da gefasst haben
dass die von unserer Regierung
respektiert wird und dass sie den
verfassungskonform wie ich
davorgezeichnet ist beschreitet um
diesen 2024er Haus
mit uns mit dem Parlament gemeinsam über
die Bühne zu bringen und zwar möglichst
möglichst ohne vorläufige
Haushaltsführung weil dann ist das
Parlament nicht beteiligt vielen
danktin Hagen auch sie Sozialdemokratin
plediert dafür den Haushalt 2024 noch in
diesem Jahr kommen zur Abstimmung über
die vorliegenden
Entschließungsanträge der
Entschließungsantrag der ja meine Damen
und Herren und an dieser Stelle
NOZ zusammenfassen was wir hier heute
erlebt haben die Regierungserklärung des
Bundeskanzlers der den Bürgern
verlässliche staatliche Leistung trotz
der Haushaltskrise zugesichert hat
zugleich aber auch Sparbeschlüsse
angedeutet hat der Staat wird seine
Aufgaben auch weiterhin gerecht werden
hat Bundeskanzler Scholz gesagt hat noch
mal gerechtfertigt dass die
Schuldenbremse auch in diesem Jahr
ausgesetzt werden muss und hat für meine
Erinnerung doch eher gesagt dass man
sich Zeit lassen muss um jetzt zu
überlegen wie man den Haushalt 24
verfassungskonform bekommt die
Sozialdemokraten in dieser Debatte haben
den Weg klar vorgezeigt sie sagen wir
wollen in diesem Jahr noch abschließen
das bedeutet die Schuldenbremse auch auf
das Jahr 2024 auszuweiten dagegen wird
sich zunächst noch die FDP und auch die
Union hat hier gesagt da würde sie nicht
mitmachen aber für diesen Schritt sind
sie auch gar nicht gebraucht sondern für
den Schritt den die grüne
Fraktionschefin dröge andeutete dass
eben die Schuldenbremse verändert werden
muss Investitionen müssen zugänglich
gemacht werden dafür bräuchte die
Bundesregierung allerdings die
Zustimmung der CDU CSU hier im Hohen
Hause denn es wäre dann eine zwei
Drittel Mehrheit notwendig um das
Grundgesetz zu verändern und noch ein
Wort zum Oppositionschef Friedrich März
hat hier wirklich in einer venten Rede
den Bundeskanzler quasi zerlegt sie sind
ein klemtner der Macht hat er ihm
vorgeworfen ihnen fehlt jliche
Vorstellung wie sich das Land entwickeln
soll verglichen mit brandschmidt
Schröder muss man spätestens nach der
heutigen Regierungserklärung feststellen
sie können es nicht und das waren Töne
die ein nicht hoffnungsvoll stimmen
können in der Frage ob in dieser Krise
Koalition und Opposition zusammengehen
können wenn man es zusammenfasst muss
man sagen die Ampel muss ich vor allen
Dingen für den Haushalt 2024
zusammenraufen ob das noch in diesem
Jahr klappt ob die Schuldenbremse ein
neues mal ausgesetzt wird für das Jahr
2024 oder ob das was der bundeskanz auch
schon gedeutet hat dass es harte
Sparbeschlüsse geben muss ob das
umgesetzt wird was auch die FDP will das
bleibt jetzt abzuwarten in den
Gesprächen der nächsten Tage und Wochen
aber wir haben ja bekanntlich schon bald
Weihnachten also ob das dieses Jahr noch
klappt wir werden es sehen ein
ereignisreicher Vormittag hier im
Deutschen Bundestag wir melden uns hier
aus dem Bundestag wieder morgen am
Mittwoch um 13 Uhr mit der Befragung der
Bundesregierung und das soll es von mir
gewesen sein ich gebe zurück zu Claudia
Davis nach Bonn ja viel